If you want more from the show, join The Rest Is History Club. And with Christmas coming, you can also gift a whole year of access to the history lover in your life. Just head to the restishistory.com and click gifts. When planning for life's most important moments, sometimes the hardest part is simply knowing where to start. That's why we're here to help. When you pre-plan and prepay a celebration of life with us, every detail will be handled with simplicity and professionalism, giving you the peace of mind that you've done all you can today to remove any burden from your loved ones tomorrow. We are your local Dignity Memorial provider. Find us at DignityMemorial.ca.
如果您想从本节目中获得更多内容，请加入“历史其余部分”俱乐部。随着圣诞节的临近，您还可以为您生命中热爱历史的人赠送一整年的会员资格。只需前往therestishistory.com并点击“礼物”即可。在规划人生中最重要的时刻时，有时最困难的部分仅仅是不知道从何开始。这就是我们在此提供帮助的原因。当您与我们一起预先规划和预付人生庆典时，每一个细节都将以简洁和专业的方式处理，让您安心，因为您今天所做的一切，都是为了减轻您所爱之人明天的负担。我们是您当地的Dignity Memorial服务提供商。请访问DignityMemorial.ca。
The Dignity Memorial brand name is used to identify a network of licensed funeral cremation and cemetery providers owned and operated by affiliates of Service Corporation International. This episode is sponsored by Hive. History has always been a story of power, who seeks it, who seizes it, and how easily it can all slip away. The Caesars, the Caliphs, the Tsars, they conquered vast swaths of the world, they proclaimed themselves, the favourites of the gods, and yet their empires crumbled away. It is easier to conquer than it is to control. Hive takes a different approach. It puts power where it belongs in your hands.
Dignity Memorial品牌名称用于标识由Service Corporation International的附属公司拥有和运营的持牌殡葬、火化和墓地服务提供商网络。本集由Hive赞助。历史一直是一个关于权力的故事，谁在寻求它，谁在夺取它，以及它是多么容易溜走。凯撒、哈里发、沙皇，他们征服了广阔的世界，他们宣称自己是上帝的宠儿，然而他们的帝国却土崩瓦解。征服比控制更容易。Hive采取了不同的方法。它将权力归还给它所属的地方——您的手中。
They started with smart thermostats, and they've been. now gone much further. Solar panels, heat pumps, EV charges, all working together so that you can power your home in your own way. That's genuine empowerment. Checking your phone, seeing the heating's on, the car's charging and the sun is quietly earning its keep on the roof. Caesar never had to charge his chariots, but I'm sure he would have admired the efficiency. Visit Hive Home com to find out more. Subject to survey and suitability, Hive compatible with selected technology.
他们从智能恒温器起家，现在已经走得更远了。太阳能电池板、热泵、电动汽车充电器，所有这些协同工作，让您可以按照自己的方式为家庭供电。这才是真正的赋权。查看您的手机，看到暖气已打开，汽车正在充电，太阳正在屋顶上静静地为您赚取收益。凯撒从未需要给他的战车充电，但我相信他会钦佩这种效率。访问HiveHome.com了解更多信息。受调查和适用性限制，Hive与选定的技术兼容。
Above all, of the cause of freedom. A tremendous battle is raging in France and Flanders. The Germans, by a remarkable combination of air bombing and heavily armored tanks, have broken through the French defenses north of the Maginot Line. If this is one of the most awe-striking periods in the long history of France and Britain, It is also beyond doubt the most sublime, side by side, unaided, except by their kith and kin in the great dominions, and by the wide empires which rest beneath their shield. Side by side, the British and French peoples have advanced to rescue not only Europe but mankind, from the foulest and most selfish. old destroying tyranny, which was ever darkened and stained the pages of history.
最重要的是，为了自由的事业。法国和法兰德斯正在进行一场激烈的战斗。德国人通过空中轰炸和重型装甲坦克的惊人组合，突破了马奇诺防线以北的法国防线。如果这是法国和英国漫长历史上最令人敬畏的时期之一，那么毫无疑问，这也是最崇高的时期。并肩作战，孤军奋战，除了得到伟大领地中亲朋好友的支持，以及在他们盾牌下休息的广大帝国的支持。英国和法国人民并肩前进，不仅是为了拯救欧洲，也是为了拯救人类，使其免受有史以来玷污历史篇章的最卑鄙、最自私、最破坏性的暴政的侵害。
Behind them? Behind us. Behind the armies and fleets of Britain and France. Gather a group of shattered states and bludgeoned races. The Czechs, the Poles, the Norwegians, the Danes, the Dains, the Dian, the Dynes, the Dynes, the The Belgians, upon all of whom the long night of barbarism will descend, unbroken even by a star of hope, unless we conquer. As conquer we must. As conquer we shall. So that, Dominic, it will stun you to learn, was Winston Churchill, and it was his first radio address as British Prime Minister
在他们身后？在我们身后。在英国和法国的军队和舰队身后。聚集了一群破碎的国家和被重创的种族。捷克人、波兰人、挪威人、丹麦人、比利时人，野蛮的漫漫长夜将降临在他们所有人身上，甚至没有一颗希望之星，除非我们征服。正如我们必须征服的那样。正如我们必将征服的那样。所以，多米尼克，你会惊讶地发现，那是温斯顿·丘吉尔，这是他作为英国首相的第一次广播讲话
delivered on the 19th of May 1940. And when he gave that address, he had been Prime Minister for only nine days. But never in history. Had anybody taken office against quite such a bleak backdrop? So we ended
发表于1940年5月19日。当他发表那次演讲时，他担任首相仅九天。但在历史上，从未有人在如此凄凉的背景下就职。所以我们结束了
our previous episode with Hitler preparing his great attack in the West, an attack that huge numbers of people in the German high command thought was a disastrous policy. But actually, In the short term, Hitler had been proved right because the blow fell on the Western armies
我们上一集的内容是希特勒准备在西部发动大进攻，德国最高统帅部的大量人员认为这是一项灾难性的政策。但实际上，在短期内，希特勒被证明是正确的，因为打击落在了西方军队身上
on the 10th of May, the very day that Churchill would become Prime Minister. And what happens next is one of the great duels, one of the great dramas, not just in European, but all world history. Yeah. So this week we're exploring the great turning point in the story of the Nazis, the events of 1940. But let's just remind ourselves where we ended last time. So Hitler in late 1939, crushed Poland, divided it with Stalin. He has escaped a possible coup by his own generals.
在5月10日，也就是丘吉尔成为首相的那一天。接下来发生的事情是伟大的决斗之一，是伟大的戏剧之一，不仅在欧洲，而且在整个世界历史上。是的。所以本周我们正在探索纳粹故事中的伟大转折点，即1940年的事件。但让我们回顾一下我们上次结束的地方。希特勒在1939年底粉碎了波兰，并与斯大林瓜分了它。他逃脱了他自己将军们可能发动的政变。
He's also escaped a bomb attack in the Munich Beer Hall. And he has told his high command to prepare an attack on France and England, as he calls it, at the earliest and most favorable moment. And that attack has been much postponed and timetabled for the spring of 1940. And we'll be coming to that attack. and to Churchill's emergence as Britain's savior later in this episode. But first, somewhere we haven't discussed at all in the whole of this series on the third right, going back four seasons, and that is the North, and the irony being that the Nazis
他还逃脱了慕尼黑啤酒馆的炸弹袭击。他告诉他的最高统帅部，要在最早和最有利的时刻准备对法国和英国（正如他所称的那样）发动攻击。这次攻击被多次推迟，并定于1940年春季进行。我们将在本集后面讨论这次攻击以及丘吉尔作为英国救星的出现。但首先，在整个关于第三帝国的系列节目中，我们完全没有讨论过一个地方，那就是北方，讽刺的是，纳粹
were so obsessed with their northern inheritance and their kind of their Nordic roots and Norse myths, but they never gave much thought to Scandinavia, really. But we mentioned the iron ore in Sweden, which I'm very excited about. Yes, and that will come. But also, you touched on Finland, didn't you? The fact that the Soviets were bogged down in the snows of that distant northern land. Yeah, it's like listen to Winston Churchill. I know I'm kind of infected by it. Yeah. The brave people of Finland. So, Finland, formerly the Grand Duchy of Finland, have been part of the Russian Empire, three and a half million people. And Stalin had attacked us at the end of November 1939 because he'd given
如此痴迷于他们的北方遗产和他们的北欧根源以及北欧神话，但他们实际上从未过多考虑斯堪的纳维亚半岛。但我们提到了瑞典的铁矿石，这让我非常兴奋。是的，那会提到的。而且你也提到了芬兰，不是吗？苏联在那个遥远北方土地的积雪中陷入困境的事实。是的，就像听温斯顿·丘吉尔的演讲一样。我知道我有点被它感染了。是的。芬兰勇敢的人民。所以，芬兰，前芬兰大公国，曾是俄罗斯帝国的一部分，有三百五十万人。斯大林在1939年11月底袭击了我们，因为他给了
an ultimatum to the Finns to hand over a chunk of Karelia, the bit of Finland that is just above Leningrad, formerly St. Petersburg. The Finns, to his great surprise, said no. Stalin sent in the Red Army, but the Red Army was useless at this stage because Stalin had killed all their generals as part of the Great Terror. He had purged them, and they were completely unprepared. We think of the Russians as supremely well equipped to fight in the winter, but they were very unprepared compared with the Finns, who were wearing these kind of white camouflage uniforms were on skis and were throwing Molotov cocktails at them, so that this is the war that gives us the Molotov cocktail.
芬兰人最后通牒，要求交出卡累利阿的一块土地，即列宁格勒（前圣彼得堡）上方的那部分芬兰领土。令他大吃一惊的是，芬兰人拒绝了。斯大林派出了红军，但红军在这一阶段毫无用处，因为斯大林在大清洗中杀死了他们所有的将军。他清洗了他们，他们完全没有准备。我们认为俄罗斯人在冬季作战方面装备精良，但与芬兰人相比，他们非常没有准备，芬兰人穿着这种白色迷彩服，滑着雪，并向他们投掷莫洛托夫鸡尾酒，所以这就是给我们带来莫洛托夫鸡尾酒的战争。
And basically, you know, Finland is clearly never going to completely win the war because it's tiny compared with the Soviet Union. Basically, the two sides had to agree a compromise. And in March 1940, the Finns handed over a chunk of Karelia, but Stalin then dropped his previous plan of basically turning Finland into a semi-absorbed client state, and he lets them keep their independence. And the result of this war, the winter war, is that the Red Army have lost about 125,000 men killed, and another 300,000 have been incapacitated by wounds, or they've basically
基本上，你知道，芬兰显然永远不会完全赢得这场战争，因为它与苏联相比太小了。基本上，双方不得不达成妥协。1940年3月，芬兰人交出了一块卡累利阿领土，但斯大林随后放弃了他之前将芬兰变成半吸收附庸国的计划，并让他们保持了独立。这场战争（冬季战争）的结果是，红军损失了约12.5万人，另有30万人因受伤而丧失战斗力，或者他们基本上
got disease, or they've got frostbites. And Hitler's been watching this, right? Yes. And so he thinks, ah, this demonstrates that the Soviet army is rubbish, and therefore it will be easy for us to conquer it. Exactly. It's really important, actually, in Hitler's thinking this so-called winter war between Finland and the USSR. Because Hitler, as he says to his top brass, we have only to kick in the door and the whole rotten structure of the Soviet Union will come crashing down. And this is what everybody believes, having watched what happened
得了疾病，或者他们得了冻疮。希特勒一直在观察这一切，对吧？是的。所以他想，啊，这证明苏联军队是垃圾，因此我们很容易征服它。没错。这在希特勒关于芬兰和苏联之间所谓的冬季战争的思考中确实非常重要。因为希特勒正如他对高级将领所说的那样，我们只需要踢开门，苏联整个腐朽的结构就会崩溃。这就是每个人在看到所发生的事情后所相信的
in Finland. Now, Finland is therefore preserved as a buffer in the north between Scandinavia and the Soviet Union. And so now Hitler can work on a plan. to bring Scandinavia into his empire. And the key thing here, which I know something that really excites you, is iron ore. There's nothing I enjoy more than a discussion about iron ore. Can I give you some stats? I'd love a iron ore statistic. So, Dominic, and listeners, here is some exciting iron ore stats,
在芬兰。现在，芬兰因此作为北方斯堪的纳维亚和苏联之间的缓冲区被保留了下来。所以现在希特勒可以制定一个计划，将斯堪的纳维亚纳入他的帝国。这里的关键点，我知道这让你非常兴奋，就是铁矿石。没有什么比讨论铁矿石更让我喜欢的了。我能给你一些统计数据吗？我很乐意听听铁矿石的统计数据。所以，多米尼克和听众们，这里有一些令人兴奋的铁矿石统计数据，
and they come from the War in the West by my brother James Holland. By December 1939, British intelligence deduced that of the 22 million tons of iron ore imported in 1938, the equivalent of 9.5 million tons of that supply had come from sources now close to it. And so that is obviously a massive crisis for the Nazi war effort, because without iron ore, they can't build their planes and guns and all that kind of stuff. And so that puts an absolute premium on the one remaining guaranteed source of iron ore, and that is Sweden. So you can see why this is a huge kind of determinant in Nazi war planning.
它们来自我兄弟詹姆斯·霍兰德的《西线战争》。到1939年12月，英国情报部门推断，在1938年进口的2200万吨铁矿石中，相当于950万吨的供应量来自现在已关闭的来源。因此，这对纳粹的战争努力显然是一个巨大的危机，因为没有铁矿石，他们就无法制造飞机、枪支和所有这些东西。因此，这使得唯一剩下的铁矿石保证来源变得极其重要，那就是瑞典。所以你可以看出为什么这是纳粹战争规划中的一个巨大决定因素。
Massive. It's absolutely massive. Isn't that interesting? I think that's interesting. It's fascinating. I think it's probably a fascinating fact we've ever had on the rest of history. So this iron ore is produced by mines in the north of Sweden. It comes out of Sweden through one port in particular, which is Narvik across the border in northern Norway. Which I think is a great name, Narvik. Yeah, I've been to Narvick, actually. Have you?
巨大的。这绝对是巨大的。这难道不有趣吗？我认为这很有趣。这太迷人了。我认为这可能是我们在“历史其余部分”中讨论过的最迷人的事实。所以这些铁矿石是由瑞典北部的矿山生产的。它通过一个特定的港口运出瑞典，即挪威北部的纳尔维克。我认为纳尔维克是一个很棒的名字。是的，我实际上去过纳尔维克。你去过吗？
Kind of nondescript. But a good name. Yeah, but a good name. So Narvick is also ice-free in winter. So you can bring iron ore all year round. Now, as soon as the war broke out in September 1939, Grand Admiral Raider of the Kriegsmarine, which is the Navy, went to Hitler and said, look, we have to guarantee this flow of iron ore from northern Sweden.
有点平淡无奇。但名字不错。是的，但名字不错。所以纳尔维克在冬天也是不结冰的。所以你可以全年运送铁矿石。现在，1939年9月战争一爆发，德国海军（Kriegsmarine）的雷德尔大元帅就去见希特勒说，看，我们必须保证来自瑞典北部的铁矿石供应。
In other words, we have to establish ourselves in Norway, which is neutral, because if we don't, the Allies will. And if they get their first, we are in real trouble. And Raider said to Hitler, this business of the Winter War in Finland is a real issue, because the Allies, I think, will use that as a pretext. They will send troops to help Finland against Stalin, and on the way, they will occupy Norway and northern Sweden. And the thing is, he's right, isn't he? Because actually the Allies do have exactly such a plan. They do, and this may surprise a lot of listeners. The Allies absolutely had such a plan.
换句话说，我们必须在挪威建立我们的立足点，挪威是中立的，因为如果我们不这样做，盟军就会这样做。如果他们先到达那里，我们就会陷入真正的麻烦。雷德尔对希特勒说，芬兰冬季战争这件事是一个真正的问题，因为盟军，我认为，会以此为借口。他们会派军队帮助芬兰对抗斯大林，在途中，他们会占领挪威和瑞典北部。问题是，他是对的，不是吗？因为实际上盟军确实有这样的计划。他们确实有，这可能会让很多听众感到惊讶。盟军绝对有这样的计划。
Churchill, now running the Admiralty, the Navy in Britain, is especially keen on it. So under his eagis, Britain and France draw up a plan to invade Denmark and Norway. Basically, if you're invading Norway, you have to take Denmark as well, because it's right next door. They would have landed troops and Narvik. They would have seized the Swedish iron mines, and they would have then pushed troops further on into Finland to help the Finns against Stalin, who at this point, they kind of perceive as Hitler's ally, his partner in crime. Now, they ended up scrapping this plan, basically in part because the Norwegians and the Swedes got wind of it. And they said, what?
现在负责英国海军部的丘吉尔对此特别热衷。因此，在他的支持下，英国和法国制定了入侵丹麦和挪威的计划。基本上，如果你要入侵挪威，你也必须占领丹麦，因为它就在隔壁。他们本会在纳尔维克登陆部队。他们本会夺取瑞典的铁矿，然后他们会把部队进一步推进到芬兰，以帮助芬兰人对抗斯大林，当时他们认为斯大林是希特勒的盟友，是他的犯罪伙伴。现在，他们最终放弃了这个计划，基本上部分原因是挪威人和瑞典人听到了风声。他们说，什么？
You're planning to occupy us. Yeah, that's not good, is it? That's outrageous. But the threat is still there. So on the 20th of February, Hitler summoned one of his generals who was called Paul von Falconhorst and said, I want you to come up with a plan to invade Norway and Denmark. And this is a very good indication of the mad way that Hitler does business. It's so funny.
你们计划占领我们。是的，那不好，不是吗？这太令人愤慨了。但威胁依然存在。因此，2月20日，希特勒召集了一位名叫保罗·冯·法尔肯霍斯特的将军，说，我希望你拿出一个入侵挪威和丹麦的计划。这很好地说明了希特勒处理事务的疯狂方式。这太搞笑了。
See, he calls to this guy Falcon Horse and says, and by the way, I need this plan. You've got until 5 o'clock this afternoon. I don't know what time it is. It's like lunchtime or something. Yeah, he's got kind of three hours. And also, you can't tell anyone about it and you can't get any help. So he goes to a bookshop, doesn't he?
你看，他叫来这个叫法尔肯霍斯特的家伙说，顺便说一句，我需要这个计划。你今天下午5点之前完成。我不知道现在几点了。就像午餐时间什么的。是的，他只有三个小时左右。而且你不能告诉任何人，你也不能寻求任何帮助。所以他去了一家书店，不是吗？
He gets a Bidica, a guide to Scandinavia. Yeah. And he books himself into a hotel, Falcon Horse, with this guidebook and sort of in desperation. He hasn't even got any maps or anything. He's just got a guidebook. Desperately scribbling, I don't know, in hotel notepaper or something. The plan to invade Norway and Denmark. Hitler was convinced this will be very easy. And by the end of March, Grand Admiral Raider has said, come on, me need to hurry up. They set the date for the 9th of April. Now, in the meantime, they obviously need a reason to go in. And ideally, they will have a local collaborator. And Raider, the admiral, says to Hitler, look, I've got the perfect person. There's this bloke from Norway. He runs a fascist party called the Nacional Samling. I think, I don't know how my Norwegian pronunciation is. And this bloke's name is Vidcon Quisling. And Quisling, you'll be delighted to hear this, Tom.
他买了一本《贝德克尔》，一本斯堪的纳维亚指南。是的。他给自己订了一家酒店，法尔肯霍斯特带着这本指南，处于绝望之中。他甚至没有任何地图之类的东西。他只有一本指南。绝望地乱涂乱画，我不知道，在酒店信纸上还是什么。入侵挪威和丹麦的计划。希特勒确信这将非常容易。到3月底，雷德尔大元帅说，来吧，我们需要抓紧时间。他们将日期定为4月9日。现在，与此同时，他们显然需要一个进入的理由。理想情况下，他们会有一个当地的合作者。雷德尔海军上将对希特勒说，看，我找到了完美的人选。挪威有个家伙。他经营着一个名为“国民联盟”（Nacional Samling）的法西斯政党。我想，我不知道我的挪威语发音如何。这个家伙的名字叫维德孔·吉斯林。吉斯林，你会很高兴听到这个，汤姆。
He's the son of a Lutheran pastor. Surely everybody in Norway is the son of a Lutheran pastor. At least 30%, I would guess. Yeah. He'd got the highest marks. in the history of the Norwegian military academy that spoke Quisling and he'd worked very closely
他是路德教牧师的儿子。肯定挪威每个人都是路德教牧师的儿子。我猜至少有30%。是的。他获得了挪威军事学院历史上最高的成绩，那个叫吉斯林的家伙，他工作非常密切
with the explorer turned refugee campaigner Fritov Nansen. Anyway, there's only about 10 people in Norway. So if you've got those high marks from the academy, you can thrive in Norwegian politics. So Quisling was defence minister very briefly. Then in the 1930s, he sort of got really into Nordic nationalism
与探险家转型的难民活动家弗里乔夫·南森一起。无论如何，挪威只有大约10个人。所以如果你在学院获得了那些高分，你就可以在挪威政治中茁壮成长。所以吉斯林曾短暂担任国防部长。然后在20世纪30年代，他开始真正沉迷于北欧民族主义
and he formed his own Nazi-style party and he called himself the Fuhrer of this party. spelt in an entertaining a Norwegian way. Yeah, so it's a no with a dash through it. Exactly. But he never did well. They were very poor. They never got more than two and a half percent of the vote.
他组建了自己的纳粹风格政党，并自称为该党的元首（Fuhrer）。以一种有趣的挪威方式拼写。是的，所以是一个带横线的o。没错。但他从未成功。他们非常贫穷。他们从未获得超过2.5%的选票。
So that's what? About six people voting for. Yeah. They never managed to elect a single Norwegian MP. Anyway, Rader brings him to Hitler and introduces him to Hitler, this guy, Quisling. And Hitler thinks that he's a bit useless. However, he's the only person they've got.
所以那是多少？大约六个人投票支持。是的。他们从未成功选出一名挪威议员。无论如何，雷德尔把他带到希特勒面前，把他介绍给希特勒，这个叫吉斯林的家伙。希特勒认为他有点没用。然而，他是他们唯一能找到的人。
So they decide to back him anyway. And Quisling does turn out to be genuinely useful to the Germans because he was defence minister, so he's able to give them details of all Norway's defences. So overt treason? Completely. I mean, he really is a Quisling. And of course, that's where the name comes from. Yeah.
所以他们决定无论如何都要支持他。吉斯林确实证明了对德国人非常有用，因为他曾担任国防部长，所以他能够向他们提供挪威所有防御工事的详细信息。所以是公开的叛国？完全是。我的意思是，他确实是一个吉斯林。当然，这就是这个名字的由来。是的。
Now, in the meantime, the Allies finally, unbelievable, they've actually got their act together and decided to do something. So the French have finally got rid of their dithering prime minister, who was Dalladier, a socialist, and they've replaced him with somebody from the other end of the political spectrum, the centre-right, Paul Reynot. And Reino is a very clever man, kind of, you know, very impressive in many ways.
现在，与此同时，盟军终于，难以置信，他们终于采取了行动，决定做点什么。所以法国人终于摆脱了他们优柔寡断的首相达拉第（一个社会主义者），并用政治光谱另一端的人，即中右翼的保罗·雷诺取代了他。雷诺是一个非常聪明的人，某种程度上，你知道，在许多方面都令人印象深刻。
He's extremely short, actually. He's five-foot-three, so that's his defining characteristic. And he, Deladier, people used to say of Deladier, he made no decisions at all, but Reynne makes a decision every five minutes, and a lot of them are mad. So he's very like Churchill.
他实际上非常矮。他只有5英尺3英寸，所以这是他的决定性特征。而且，人们过去常说达拉第，他根本不做任何决定，但雷诺每五分钟就做一个决定，而且很多决定都很疯狂。所以他非常像丘吉尔。
He loves kind of mad invasion. of remote, distant places. That's his vibe, isn't it? He loves all that. Right. A wheeze. Yeah. So he's very keen on the idea of landing in Norway,
他喜欢那种疯狂的入侵。偏远、遥远的地方。那是他的风格，不是吗？他喜欢所有这些。对。一个妙计。是的。所以他非常热衷于在挪威登陆的想法，
and he also wanted to attack Soviet oil fields in Baku in Azerbaijan. I mean, that seems mad. Indeed. Anyway, after a lot of dithering about this, the French and the British finally agree they will intervene in Norway. They will mine the waters around Narvik. That's the crucial port the Germans get their iron ore from. Now, they know that if they mine these waters, there will be a German reaction.
他还想攻击阿塞拜疆巴库的苏联油田。我的意思是，这看起来太疯狂了。确实。总之，在对此犹豫不决了很久之后，英法终于同意干预挪威。他们将封锁纳尔维克周围的水域。那是德国人获取铁矿石的关键港口。现在，他们知道如果封锁这些水域，德国人会有所反应。
So they say we'll also have to send troops and occupy Norway's western ports. So that's Narvik, Stavanger, Bergen, places like that. And how do the Norwegians feel about this? Gutted, I think. Are they told or are they just going to turn up and occupy them? Yeah, as we shall see, the Norwegians, when the war breaks out, they don't know who started it, the Allies or the Germans. So that tells its own story, really. Right.
所以他们说我们也必须派遣军队占领挪威的西部港口。也就是纳尔维克、斯塔万格、卑尔根之类的地方。挪威人对此有何感想？我想他们一定很痛苦。他们是被告知了，还是盟军只是突然出现并占领了这些地方？是的，正如我们将要看到的，当战争爆发时，挪威人甚至不知道是谁先挑起的，是盟军还是德国人。所以这本身就说明了问题。没错。
So at the beginning of April, Churchill, who is really responsible for all this and basically, ought to carry the can when it goes horribly wrong. I mean, it's so Gallipoli, isn't it? Yeah, I mean, he never learns really, does he? He decides he'll kick it off. He sends four destroyers to lay these minds. But I mean, I guess the reason that he doesn't end up carrying the can
所以四月初，丘吉尔，他实际上对这一切负有责任，基本上，当事情变得一团糟时，他应该承担责任。我的意思是，这太像加里波利战役了，不是吗？是的，我的意思是，他真的从不吸取教训，对吧？他决定亲自发起行动。他派了四艘驱逐舰去布雷。但我猜他最终没有承担责任的原因是
is because Chamberlain on the 3rd of April, he addresses the Conservative National Union and he makes a kind of fateful boast, doesn't he? Whatever reason Hitler had for not making an immediate endeavor to overwhelm us, one thing is certain, he has missed the bus. And that phrase, Hitler has missed the bass, will return to haunt Chamberlain. Indeed. Because actually, while the Allies have been messing around and dithering with their mad
因为张伯伦在4月3日向保守党全国联盟发表讲话时，做出了某种致命的吹嘘，不是吗？无论希特勒出于什么原因没有立即努力压倒我们，有一点是肯定的，他错过了时机。而那句“希特勒错过了时机”，将一直困扰着张伯伦。确实。因为实际上，当盟军一直在胡闹和犹豫不决，带着他们疯狂的
ideas, Hitler has made up his own mind, and he has already sent the German fleet to begin the operation against Norway. Now, the British, this speaks volumes about the quality of Britain's decision-making at this point. The British have intelligence to say the Germans have put to sea, but they say, yeah, they're probably not going to Norway. I imagine they're going to try and break through into the Atlantic. So, you know, let's not over-stress about that.
想法时，希特勒已经下定了决心，他已经派遣德国舰队开始针对挪威的行动。现在，英国人，这充分说明了英国此时决策的质量。英国人有情报显示德国人已经出海，但他们说，是的，他们可能不会去挪威。我想他们是想尝试突破进入大西洋。所以，你知道，别太紧张了。
Early on the 8th of April, the British start to lay their minds outside Narvik. But the Germans are approaching all the time. My brother's brilliant on this, and he writes, it was incredible that after so much allied vacillation over Norway, both sides should have been beginning their offens at the same moment and both be ignorant of the other's plans. I mean, that is kind of mad, isn't it? It's crazy.
4月8日一早，英国人开始在纳尔维克外布雷。但德国人一直在逼近。我兄弟对此写得非常精彩，他写道，令人难以置信的是，在盟军对挪威问题如此犹豫不决之后，双方竟然在同一时刻开始进攻，而且都不知道对方的计划。我的意思是，这有点疯狂，不是吗？这太疯狂了。
So midnight on the 8th, the Norwegians realized something is up. up. And the Norwegian side of the story is great, actually, and I shall be referring listeners to some excellent films on this made in Norway. It's about 1.30 in the morning, an aide comes in to wake the king, who is called Hawken the 7th. And he is a very sort of tall gaunt man, if you Google him. He's actually a Dane. So they had to pick a new king when they broke away from Sweden at the beginning of the 20th century. And they'd pick this Danish bloke. He's got an absolutely your first-class mustache. He sent his son to Balliol College, Oxford, which I think reflects very well on him. Anyway, there he is in bed, and his aide says, Majesty, we're at war. And the
所以8日午夜，挪威人意识到出事了。挪威方面的故事其实很棒，我将向听众推荐一些在挪威制作的优秀电影。大约凌晨1点半，一名助手进来叫醒国王，他叫哈康七世。如果你谷歌一下他，他是一个非常高大憔悴的人。他实际上是丹麦人。所以当他们在20世纪初脱离瑞典时，他们不得不选一位新国王。他们选了这个丹麦家伙。他留着绝对一流的胡子。他把儿子送到牛津大学贝利奥尔学院，我认为这对他评价很高。总之，他躺在床上，助手说，陛下，我们开战了。而
king says, with whom? You know, because they don't know whether it's going to be the Germans or the Allies. Exactly the same thing happens in Iceland, doesn't it? Yeah. The British do go and occupy Iceland. Yeah. And they say, who is it? And they say the British, and they go, few. Because better than the British than the Germans, I guess. It's nice that people think that way about us. I'm sure everybody in the world thinks that way about when the British turn up, then they? That's the impression I get from the history books I read. Anyway, so there's a very comic side to the Norwegian resistance. So this is my favorite bit. Norway's commander-in-chief was an elderly general called General Larka. I don't think
国王说，和谁？你知道，因为他们不知道是德国人还是盟军。冰岛也发生了完全一样的事情，不是吗？是的。英国人确实去占领了冰岛。是的。他们问，是谁？他们说是英国人，然后他们说，呼。因为我觉得被英国人占领总比被德国人占领好。人们这样看待我们真是太好了。我相信世界上每个人在英国人出现时都会这样想，对吧？这就是我从读过的历史书中得到的印象。总之，挪威的抵抗有一面非常滑稽。这是我最喜欢的部分。挪威的总司令是一位叫拉尔克将军的老年人。我不认为
Norwegians had ever really, not since Harold Hardrada really, had they extended themselves militarily. So General Larker is told, the Germans are coming up the Oslo Fjord. Ships are, you know, coming through the fog or whatever. And he says, right, call out the reserves. like, send out the letters. And someone said, what, the letters? I mean, they're not going to get here for days. We can do it all by post. Yeah, you know what the post is like in Norway.
挪威人真的，自哈拉尔·哈德拉达以来，在军事上真的扩展过自己。所以拉尔克将军被告知，德国人正沿着奥斯陆峡湾上来。船只，你知道，正穿过雾气什么的。他说，好吧，召集预备役。就像，发出信件。有人说，什么，信件？我的意思是，他们几天内都不会到这里。我们可以全部通过邮寄完成。是的，你知道挪威的邮政是什么样的。
Yeah. Anyway, staff officers remonstrated with him and he said, it's fine. There's no hurry. Don't overthink this. Just write them letters. They'll turn up. And then he said, I need to go back to my farm. This is my favorite detail, to get my toilet dress.
是的。总之，参谋军官劝阻他，他说，没关系。不用着急。别想太多。只要写信给他们。他们会出现的。然后他说，我需要回我的农场。这是我最喜欢的细节，去拿我的洗漱用品。
He basically has to get his wash bag from his farms. He goes out to his farm and collects his, like, a change of clothes, some underwear, you know, toothbrush, whatever. And then he calls a taxi. But because the invasion has begun, the taxi is very, very severely delayed. It takes ages to this taxi to arrive. The taxi picks him up and takes him back to Oslo to a Norwegian army headquarters. By the time he gets there with his washbag, the general staff have evacuated and they haven't left any information to tell him where they've gone. Isn't the spirit of Harold Hardrada, is it?
他基本上必须从他的农场拿他的洗漱包。他去他的农场收集他的，比如，换洗的衣服，一些内衣，你知道，牙刷什么的。然后他叫了一辆出租车。但因为入侵已经开始，出租车被非常非常严重地延误了。这辆出租车花了很长时间才到达。出租车接上他，带他回奥斯陆的挪威陆军总部。当他带着洗漱包到达那里时，参谋部已经撤离了，他们没有留下任何信息告诉他他们去了哪里。这可不是哈拉尔·哈德拉达的精神，是吧？
So he then works out where they've gone. He gets a tram, a suburban tram, carrying his stuff as far as he can, to the end of the line. And then he walked to the Norwegian Map Institute to see if they had a car that he could borrow to take him to meet his men. They don't have a car. So then he had to walk all the way back to the railway station to get a train. And it's hours and hours until he finally rejoins his. stuff. So Blitzkrieg, it is not. Well, do you know what? That sounds like I'm dissing the Norwegians
所以他后来弄清楚了他们去了哪里。他坐了一辆电车，一辆郊区电车，带着他的东西尽可能远地走，直到线路尽头。然后他走到挪威地图研究所，看看他们是否有车可以借给他，带他去见他的部下。他们没有车。所以他不得不一路走回火车站去坐火车。过了好几个小时，他终于重新加入了他的部下。所以这绝不是闪电战。好吧，你知道吗？这听起来像是在贬低挪威人
and I'm not because they put up some pretty stout resistance. The Germans have come up the Oslo Fjord in this cruiser, the Bluja with thousands of troops. There's a whole film about this called Bluca, a Norwegian film that came out in September. You can see clips from it on YouTube. The Norwegians have this fortress called the Oscarsborg, and it has two 19th century antique cannons. And basically, this Bluca comes closer and closer. These guys wait. at this fortress until it's really close. Then they fire with these antique cannons. They hit the Bluca's fuel store.
但我没有，因为他们进行了相当顽强的抵抗。德国人乘坐这艘巡洋舰“布吕歇尔号”带着数千名士兵沿着奥斯陆峡湾上来。有一部关于这个的完整电影叫《国王的选择》，一部九月份上映的挪威电影。你可以在YouTube上看到它的片段。挪威人有这个叫奥斯卡斯堡的堡垒，它有两门19世纪的古董大炮。基本上，这艘“布吕歇尔号”越来越近。这些人在堡垒里等着，直到它非常近。然后他们用这些古董大炮开火。他们击中了“布吕歇尔号”的燃料库。
The Bluca explodes, bursts into flames and explodes, and 800 of the Germans were drowned. So it was a big win that for the Norwegians. And because of scenes like this, this gave the king, King Horkin and his ministers, time to get out of Oslo. They managed to smuggle out the gold reserves as well, don't they? Kind of pretty much under the noses of the Germans.
“布吕歇尔号”爆炸，燃起大火并爆炸，800名德国人溺水身亡。所以这对挪威人来说是一场大胜。由于这样的场景，这给了国王哈康和他的大臣们离开奥斯陆的时间。他们还设法走私出了黄金储备，不是吗？几乎是在德国人的眼皮底下。
Yeah, it's a great story. I mean, as we'll see. it makes a great film. Because they head to this village called Elverham, which is about 40 miles north of Oslo. And they're being pursued the whole time by German paratroopers, who've been basically told,
是的，这是一个伟大的故事。我的意思是，正如我们将要看到的。它拍成了一部伟大的电影。因为他们前往这个叫埃尔沃吕姆的村庄，距离奥斯陆以北约40英里。他们一直被德国伞兵追赶，这些伞兵基本上被告知，
get the Norwegian government and get the king, like we'll need them. The local rifle club, the Elverham Rifle Club, put up a roadblock and basically drove back these German paratroopers. I mean, that's incredible. These blokes were like hunting rifles or whatever.
抓住挪威政府，抓住国王，因为我们需要他们。当地的步枪俱乐部，埃尔沃吕姆步枪俱乐部，设置了路障，基本上击退了这些德国伞兵。我的意思是，这太不可思议了。这些家伙拿着猎枪什么的。
These ordinary Norwegians managed to drive them back. And that gave the king and his, entourage time to get away. And they had a meeting. And basically, the king is told the Germans want Quisling to run a puppet government and you have to approve it. And the king says it's a very sort of stirring scene. He says to his ministers, look, there's no way I'm going to accept this, no way whatsoever. He says, if you want to accept it, fine, but I will abdicate. I will never ever preside over a Quisling government. And then he burst into tears. And it's a very stirring scene. There's a Norwegian film of this called The King's Choice. I fell down a massive rabbit
这些普通的挪威人设法击退了他们。这给了国王和他的随从逃脱的时间。他们开了一个会。基本上，国王被告知德国人想要吉斯林来管理傀儡政府，你必须批准它。国王说，这是一个非常令人振奋的场景。他对他的大臣们说，看，我绝不会接受这个，绝不。他说，如果你想接受，没问题，但我会退位。我永远不会主持一个吉斯林政府。然后他泪流满面。这是一个非常令人振奋的场景。有一部关于这个的挪威电影叫《国王的选择》。我掉进了一个巨大的兔子洞
hole and ended up watching huge chunks of this film. It's really moving, actually. It's a really moving story. Now, meanwhile, further south, the Germans have also invaded Denmark, which is the country that King Hogan had been born into, because he's from the Danish royal family originally. And there the story is a bit different. And I mean that has no disrespect to the Danes, but the geography is just not in the Danes favour. Yeah, well, also, they've got a land border with Germany, so the panzers presumably can just roll through Schleswig Holstein. Which is exactly what they do. So they kick off at 4.15 in the morning.
最后看了这部电影的大部分片段。它真的很感人，实际上。这是一个非常感人的故事。现在，与此同时，在更南边，德国人也入侵了丹麦，这是哈康国王出生的国家，因为他最初来自丹麦王室。那里的故事有点不同。我的意思是，这并不是对丹麦人的不尊重，但地理位置对丹麦人来说并不有利。是的，好吧，他们和德国有陆地边界，所以装甲部队大概可以直接穿过石勒苏益格-荷尔斯泰因。这正是他们所做的。所以他们在凌晨4点15分开始行动。
The panzers roll over naval landings, paratroopers, and the Danes are completely nutty helpless. There's a bit of fighting around the royal palace in Copenhagen. But the king of Denmark, Christian the 10th, who is actually the Norwegian king's older brother, he can see that this is totally pointless. There's no geographical barriers. The Germans are just sort of rolling into Denmark. And by breakfast, he has ordered a ceasefire, and they signed the capitulation at 10 o'clock in the morning. That was the shortest campaign of the entire war.
装甲部队碾压了海军登陆、伞兵，丹麦人完全无助。哥本哈根王宫周围有一些战斗。但丹麦国王克里斯蒂安十世，他实际上是挪威国王的哥哥，他可以看出这完全没有意义。没有地理屏障。德国人只是在进入丹麦。到早餐时，他已经下令停火，他们在上午10点签署了投降书。那是整个战争中最短的战役。
So that's five and three-quarters hours. Yeah, from start to finish. Like, it's perfectly plausible if you had a lion that day, you could wake up and not know that an invasion had happened and was finished. So my brother goes so far as to say, surely the fastest conquest of a country in history. Yeah, quite possibly. And actually, I definitely don't want to disrespect. The king of Denmark, because King Christian, he didn't go into exile. as many monarchs did, because his son's wife, Crown Princess Ingrid, who was, I think, Swedish,
所以那是五个半小时。是的，从开始到结束。就像，如果你那天睡懒觉，你完全有可能醒来时不知道入侵已经发生并结束了。所以我兄弟甚至说，这肯定是历史上最快的国家征服。是的，很有可能。实际上，我绝对不想不尊重丹麦国王，因为克里斯蒂安国王，他没有流亡，像许多君主那样，因为他儿子的妻子，王储妃英格丽德，我想她是瑞典人，
she was nine months pregnant and she couldn't travel. So he has to stay in Copenhagen. But he behaves tremendously well, doesn't he? Yeah. Very moving and powerful symbol of resistance. Very moving. He rides every day through Copenhagen on his horse, and the people gather and they cheer him and stuff. Everyone knows he is not keen on the Nazis and all of this.
她怀孕九个月了，无法旅行。所以他必须留在哥本哈根。但他表现得非常好，不是吗？是的。非常感人和强大的抵抗象征。非常感人。他每天骑马穿过哥本哈根，人们聚集在一起为他欢呼。每个人都知道他不赞成纳粹等等。
And most famously, he said to the Germans, If you make the Danish Jews wear yellow stars, then I will wear one too, and basically all my people will wear them. I think it reflects tremendously well on him. You can see, again, you can see footage online of him riding through Copenhagen. Good for him. Brilliant. But the Norwegians can hold out much longer because of the mountains and stuff.
最著名的是，他对德国人说，如果你让丹麦犹太人戴黄色星星，那么我也会戴一个，基本上我所有的人民都会戴上它们。我认为这对他评价很高。你可以再次在网上看到他骑马穿过哥本哈根的镜头。为他点赞。太棒了。但挪威人因为山脉等原因可以坚持更久。
So by contrast, that campaign lasted for two months longer than any other German invasion campaign except for the invasion of the Soviet Union. So fair play to the Norwegians. And they were not a marshal people, but about 40,000 of them immediately volunteered. They fought very bravely. They didn't have decent equipment, but they really acquitted themselves well. Now, we are a patriotic podcast, but unfortunately, this is not something that can be said of the British. Or our gallant allies, the French.
相比之下，那场战役持续了两个月，比除入侵苏联以外的任何其他德国入侵战役都要长。所以挪威人干得好。他们不是一个尚武的民族，但大约有4万名挪威人立即志愿参战。他们打得非常勇敢。他们没有像样的装备，但他们确实表现得很好。现在，我们是一个爱国播客，但不幸的是，这不能用在英国人身上。或者我们英勇的盟友，法国人。
Do they let themselves down? We absolutely disgraced ourselves. To quote Max Hastings in his book on the Second World War, our campaign was characterized by utter moral ignobility and military incompetence. So that's a shame. Oh, dear. So basically, part of this is because a lot of the best troops are stationed in France. So the British government sent some territorial reserve battalions, and they were absolutely useless.
他们让自己失望了吗？我们绝对丢尽了脸。引用马克斯·黑斯廷斯在他关于第二次世界大战的书中的话，我们的战役以彻底的道德卑劣和军事无能为特征。所以这很遗憾。哦，天哪。所以基本上，部分原因是许多最好的部队驻扎在法国。所以英国政府派了一些领土预备役营，他们完全没用。
They didn't have maps, a lot of them. They didn't have radios. They didn't have heavy weapons. They had the wrong shoes, ironically. Oh, did they? They did. Oh, well, we like that. They get into fights with local fishermen.
他们没有地图，很多人都没有。他们没有无线电。他们没有重武器。讽刺的是，他们穿错了鞋子。哦，是吗？他们确实穿错了。哦，好吧，我们喜欢那样。他们和当地渔民打架。
My favourite moment, Admiral Lord Cork, who was a very short man, wants to inspire his men to get off their ships and advance on Narvik, and they're very reluctant to do so, and he says, I'll lead you ashore. And he gets off the ship, and because he's a very short man, he falls into a snowdrift and has to be dug out by the rest of the men. So not the most glorious moment in British military history. No. So we did land in central Norway.
我最喜欢的时刻，科克海军上将，一个非常矮的人，想激励他的部下离开船只向纳尔维克推进，他们非常不情愿这样做，他说，我带你们上岸。他下了船，因为他个子很矮，掉进了雪堆里，不得不被其他人挖出来。所以这不是英国军事史上最光荣的时刻。不。所以我们确实在挪威中部登陆了。
We did capture Narvik and then recapture it. But basically, Churchill is constantly coming up with schemes of various kinds, which end up being ditched. To quote Max Hastings again, Churchill shouted loudest, but his extravagant schemes were frustrated by the lack of means to fulfill them. Do you know what's even worse about that? In his office in the Admiralty, opposite his desk, who do you think Churchill has a portrait of? Surely Admiral Lord Nelson. It is Admiral Lord Nelson, whose record in Scandinavian conflict was a whole lot better. Yeah, but also Nelson was rubbish on land, to be fair.
我们确实占领了纳尔维克，然后又夺回了它。但基本上，丘吉尔不断提出各种各样的计划，最终都被放弃了。再次引用马克斯·黑斯廷斯的话，丘吉尔喊得最响，但他的奢侈计划因缺乏实现手段而受挫。你知道关于那件事更糟糕的是什么吗？在他的海军部办公室里，在他办公桌对面，你认为丘吉尔挂着谁的肖像？肯定是纳尔逊海军上将。确实是纳尔逊海军上将，他在斯堪的纳维亚冲突中的记录要好得多。是的，但公平地说，纳尔逊在陆地上也很烂。
So landings in Norway were precisely the kind of thing that Nelson would have made a terrible hash of. Do you not think? Yeah, but not as big a hash as Churchill did. That's Churchill made of Norway, no, I know, absolutely. And the worst thing is, when the British and French decide to pull the plug and they're going to have to evacuate, they didn't have the decency to tell the Norwegians. So they were dishonest with them until the final moment. So what's it? Max Hastings said, moral ignobility.
所以挪威的登陆正是纳尔逊会搞得一团糟的那种事情。你不觉得吗？是的，但没有丘吉尔搞得那么糟。那是丘吉尔在挪威搞的，不，我知道，绝对是。最糟糕的是，当英法决定放弃并准备撤离时，他们没有礼貌告诉挪威人。所以他们直到最后一刻都在欺骗他们。所以这是什么？马克斯·黑斯廷斯说，道德卑劣。
Yeah, moral ignobility and military incompetence. And actually, when the British finally did pull the blug and the Norwegian commander-in-chief, man called Otto Ruger, when he found out, he said very bitterly, So Norway is to share the fate of Czechoslovakia and Poland. And that's a crucial point. Yeah. You keep promising to people that you will defend them and uphold their independence. And basically, the lesson of history is that Britain and France will let you down.
是的，道德卑劣和军事无能。实际上，当英国人最终放弃时，挪威总司令，一个叫奥托·鲁格的人，当他发现时，他非常痛苦地说，所以挪威要分担捷克斯洛伐克和波兰的命运。这是一个关键点。是的。你不断向人们承诺你会保护他们并维护他们的独立。基本上，历史的教训是英国和法国会让你失望。
Yeah, they'll cut and run. They'll cut and run. So you might be better off surrendering to them. the Germans. Exactly. Now, the Germans haven't completely had it their own way, and this is important. In the Norwegian campaign, they lost more than 20 cruisers and destroyers lost, or they were badly damaged, including the Bluquer, including the Bluja. And the Luftwaffe have lost almost 250 planes, and that will really matter later on in the Battle of Britain when every ship and every plane counts. So that will matter. But the big picture, once again, Hitler was
是的，他们会溜之大吉。他们会溜之大吉。所以你可能最好向德国人投降。完全正确。现在，德国人并没有完全如愿以偿，这一点很重要。在挪威战役中，他们损失了超过20艘巡洋舰和驱逐舰，或者严重受损，包括“布吕歇尔号”。德国空军损失了近250架飞机，这在后来的不列颠战役中非常重要，因为每一艘船和每一架飞机都很重要。所以这很重要。但大局上，希特勒再一次
rolled the dice. Once again, he's worn. He's got his iron ore. He's got Norway's naval bases. And he's shown his men that the British and French are basically useless and can be beaten. So, you know, it's a series of wins for him. The big consequence, of course, is political. Because there is a general sense, I think, that has been gathering all through the phony war, first France and then in Britain, that the governments of peacetime are just not up to the challenge. So as Paul Rayno said to one of his own colleagues, Britain's government is full of old men who do not know how to take a risk. But isn't the paradox that the one guy who does love a risk is Churchill, and he's just completely goofed? So actually, they would have been better not invading Norway at all.
掷了骰子。他又一次穿上了军装。他拿到了铁矿石。他拿到了挪威的海军基地。他向部下证明了英法两国基本上是无用的，是可以被打败的。所以，你知道，对他来说这是一连串的胜利。当然，最大的后果是政治上的。因为我认为，在整个“假战”期间，法国和英国都普遍存在一种感觉，即和平时期的政府根本无法应对挑战。正如保罗·雷诺对他的一位同事所说，英国政府里全是些不知道如何冒险的老头子。但矛盾之处难道不在于，唯一热爱冒险的人是丘吉尔，而他却把事情搞砸了吗？所以实际上，他们最好根本不要入侵挪威。
I suppose so. Either make it in their minds and doing it early and doing it properly, or yeah, probably not doing it at all, I guess. And really, he more than anyone, Churchill more than anyone, deserves the blame for what went wrong in Norway. But the irony is that at the time, most people say, well, this is typical of Chamberlain. Chamberlain is cautious, he's pettifogging. And also his whole Hitler missing the bus stuff. Hitler missing the bus. He's messing around with his umbrella when he should be invading Scandinavian countries. useless.
我想是这样。要么在他们心中下定决心，尽早行动并妥善执行，要么，我想，可能根本就不该行动。而且说实话，丘吉尔比任何人都更应该为挪威的失利负责。但讽刺的是，当时大多数人都说，这很符合张伯伦的作风。张伯伦谨慎、琐碎。还有他那套希特勒错失良机的说法。希特勒错失良机。他本该入侵斯堪的纳维亚国家，却在摆弄他的雨伞。没用。
And so on the 7th of May, there was this famous debate in the House of Commons, the Norway debate, probably the most famous, most celebrated debate in British parliamentary history. Yeah, I thought so. Got to be up there. And that evening of 7th of May is when Leo A. Maria, Conservative MP famously points at Chamberlain and quotes Oliver Cromwell, in the name of God, go. And the next evening, the 8th of May, more than 100 Conservative MPs desert the government, and it's obvious that something has to change. So on the 9th, just to really simplify matters, cut a long story short, Chamberlain decides to resign.
于是，5月7日，下议院举行了著名的“挪威辩论”，这可能是英国议会史上最著名、最受推崇的辩论。是的，我也这么认为。肯定名列前茅。5月7日那天晚上，保守党议员利奥·埃默里（Leo Amery）指着张伯伦，引用奥利弗·克伦威尔的话说：“以上帝的名义，走吧。”第二天晚上，即5月8日，100多名保守党议员背弃了政府，很明显必须做出改变。所以到了9号，为了简化问题，长话短说，张伯伦决定辞职。
There's a question about whether the new Prime Minister will be Lord Halifax. A very tall Foreign Secretary, isn't he? Not so warlike. Not so warlike, I think, would be a good way of describing him. Yeah. Or Churchill, who has made a terrible horlicks of Norway. But does love a war. He loves war.
关于新首相是否会是哈利法克斯勋爵，存在一个疑问。他是一位非常高大的外交大臣，不是吗？不那么好战。我想，用“不那么好战”来形容他很合适。是的。或者丘吉尔，他在挪威搞得一团糟。但他确实热爱战争。他热爱战争。
And had forecast that Hitler had to be resisted. Exactly. And that evening, Neville Chamberlain goes to Buckingham Palace to resign, and he says to George the 6th, it's Churchill. Send for Churchill. Now, meanwhile, that very evening, while that is happening, on the outskirts of Berlin, a train which is called the America pulls out of a small isolated station
并且预言必须抵抗希特勒。没错。那天晚上，内维尔·张伯伦前往白金汉宫辞职，他对乔治六世说，是丘吉尔。召见丘吉尔。现在，与此同时，就在那天晚上，当这一切发生时，在柏林郊外，一列名为“美利坚”号的火车驶出了一个小而偏僻的车站。
on the edge of the capital and it's heading west and this is Hitler's special armoured train and do you know what Gerring's train was called Asia Was it really called Asia? Yeah, Asia I guess Yeah, surely decorated with hunting trophies Yeah, apparently it was massively better decorated than Hitler's
在首都边缘，它正向西行驶，这是希特勒的专用装甲列车。你知道戈林的火车叫什么吗？“亚洲”号。真的叫“亚洲”号吗？是的，我想是“亚洲”号。确实，装饰着狩猎战利品。是的，显然它比希特勒的装饰要豪华得多。
You astound me with looted art And a gigantic buffet car Yeah, and a very luxurious toilet, I imagine. Yeah, and a whole wardrobe full of white suits. Exactly. Because actually, Goring had a model train. He loved model trains. Like, well, Disney.
你用掠夺来的艺术品让我大吃一惊。还有一个巨大的餐车。是的，我想还有一个非常豪华的厕所。是的，还有一整柜的白色西装。没错。因为实际上，戈林有一个模型火车。他喜欢模型火车。就像，嗯，迪士尼。
Yeah. Wow. Well, I mean, not in every aspect, but on the model train enthusiasm front. Right, Gregie. Disney didn't command an Air Force. A beaten Air Force, no. Anyway, so there he is on the America, and his secretures think they're all going to Denmark to visit the troops.
是的。哇。嗯，我是说，不是在每个方面，但在模型火车的热情方面。对，格雷格。迪士尼可没有指挥空军。一支被打败的空军，没有。总之，他就在“美利坚”号上，他的秘书们以为他们都要去丹麦访问部队。
And Hitler seems in tremendous form. He's very excited, clearly, and they think this is because he's going to be visiting the army in Denmark. But just after midnight around Hanover, the train switches from the northbound to the westbound tracks, kind of quietly. It switches, and they carry on rolling through the night. And the train grinds to a halt, and dawn is breaking, and they get out. There are no station signs, but actually they have arrived near the town of Eiskirchen, which is about 30 miles from the Belgian border. And here there are cars waiting to take them through the woods to the bunkers of the new Fuhrer headquarters, the Fielder Nest, the Rock Erie.
希特勒看起来状态极佳。他显然非常兴奋，他们认为这是因为他要去访问丹麦的军队。但午夜过后，在汉诺威附近，火车悄悄地从北行轨道切换到了西行轨道。它切换了，他们继续在夜色中行驶。火车缓缓停下，黎明破晓，他们走了出来。没有车站标志，但实际上他们已经到达了艾斯基兴镇附近，距离比利时边境约30英里。这里有汽车等着带他们穿过树林，前往新的元首总部——“野战巢”（Felsennest），即“岩石巢穴”。
God, he did have ludicrously named headquarters, didn't he? I mean, he couldn't be more Bonneville if he tried. Very Bonneville. And they gather in front of Hitler's newly built bunker, which he's going to be sharing with his adjutant and with the head of the armed forces, Wilhelm Keitel. and far away through the woods they can hear the telltale thump of shellfire and Hitler looks around and he says to them gentlemen the offensive against the Western powers has begun
天哪，他的总部名字确实很荒谬，不是吗？我的意思是，如果他想的话，他不可能起得更像邦纳维尔了。非常邦纳维尔。他们聚集在希特勒新建的掩体前，他将与他的副官和武装部队总司令威廉·凯特尔共享这个掩体。在远处的树林里，他们能听到炮火的阵阵轰鸣，希特勒环顾四周，对他们说：“先生们，针对西方列强的进攻已经开始了。”
and so it begins and it will be beginning after a break and now it's time for a very special segment of today's episode which we're calling the great guest of history where we explore those moments where being the perfect or indeed the worst kind of host or guest changed the course of history. And it's brought to you by our friends at EE, who have the UK's best mobile network and broadband technology. And while EEE have definitely got hosts and guests alike covered this Christmas, there have been a fair share of banquets, balls and feasts, where hospitality has shaped the course of history
于是它开始了，休息过后它将继续开始。现在是今天节目中一个非常特别的环节，我们称之为“历史上的伟大客人”，我们将探索那些作为完美或最糟糕的主人或客人如何改变历史进程的时刻。本环节由我们的朋友EE赞助，他们拥有英国最好的移动网络和宽带技术。虽然EE在这个圣诞节肯定为主人和客人都提供了保障，但历史上曾有过不少宴会、舞会和盛宴，好客之道塑造了历史的进程。
and the destiny of all those involved. Yeah, so when I'm thinking about connectivity and where it's gone wrong, I always think, Tom, of the great get-together in the early 1900s at the Hunting Lodge in Germany where Kaiser Wilhelm I, a great friend of the rest of history, welcomed some of his top generals,
以及所有相关人员的命运。是的，所以当我在思考连接性以及它在何处出错时，我总是会想到汤姆，想到20世纪初在德国狩猎小屋举行的一次盛大聚会，凯撒威廉一世，一位“历史其余部分”的好朋友，欢迎了他的一些高级将领。
and among them was Dietrich Graf von Hulzen-Haisler, who tried to entertain everybody at this feast by dressing up in a ballerina's tutu and he did a series of capers and pirouettes, but he unfortunately had a heart attack and died, and precisely because they didn't have the connectivity they needed. They weren't able to contact the emergency services in time. Dietrich Graf and Herzlert-Gaaselah breathed his last.
其中就有迪特里希·格拉夫·冯·胡尔森-海斯勒（Dietrich Graf von Hülsen-Haeseler），他试图在这次宴会上通过打扮成芭蕾舞演员的短裙来娱乐大家，他做了一系列跳跃和旋转，但不幸的是，他心脏病发作去世了，正是因为他们没有所需的连接性。他们没能及时联系到紧急服务部门。迪特里希·格拉夫·冯·胡尔森-海斯勒咽下了最后一口气。
It found it very hard to get him out of his tutu because rigamorke set in, and as a result, Europe was engulfed in the First World War. Goodness, if only they had had EE in the Kaiser's Hunting Lodge, And that is it for our special segment, the great guest of history. Needless to say, a lot of that drama might have been avoided with today's levels of connectivity. So if you're hosting or guesting this festive season, you can avoid any history-shaping drama with the UK's best mobile network and broadband technology from EE. Now, if you're hosting EE has full fibre, the UK's very best broadband technology. and that can handle all of your visitors, streaming, scrolling and gaming.
他们发现很难把他从短裙里弄出来，因为尸僵已经开始了，结果，欧洲陷入了第一次世界大战。天哪，如果他们在凯撒的狩猎小屋里有EE就好了。这就是我们“历史上的伟大客人”特别环节的全部内容。不用说，如果拥有今天的连接水平，很多戏剧性事件本可以避免。所以，如果你在这个节日期间担任主人或客人，你可以利用EE英国最好的移动网络和宽带技术来避免任何改变历史的戏剧性事件。现在，如果你是主人，EE拥有全光纤，这是英国最好的宽带技术，可以处理你所有访客的流媒体、浏览和游戏需求。
And if you're guesting, EE has their very best mobile network to keep you connected to everything from music to maps so you can stay entertained and on time. It's week three of Canadian tires early Black Friday sale. These prices won't go lower this year. Maybe too long. Freezing. Save up to 50% November 20th to 27.
如果你是客人，EE拥有他们最好的移动网络，让你与音乐、地图等一切保持连接，这样你就可以保持娱乐并准时。这是加拿大轮胎公司（Canadian Tire）提前黑色星期五促销的第三周。这些价格今年不会再低了。也许太长了。冻结。11月20日至27日最高可节省50%。
Conditions apply, details online. Hello and welcome back to the rest of history. Dominic, we ended that first half with literal bombshells. Hitler has finally launched his attack on the West. And how have we got here? Because the last time the Nazis were invading places, it was in Scandinavia. Well, as we saw last time in the last episode, Hitler's always had this very clear idea that he wants to attack the West. He wants to launch a preemptive strike.
条件适用，详情在线。你好，欢迎回到“历史的其余部分”。多米尼克，我们以真正的重磅炸弹结束了上半场。希特勒终于对西方发动了进攻。我们是怎么走到这一步的？因为纳粹上次入侵的地方是在斯堪的纳维亚。嗯，正如我们上次在上一集中看到的那样，希特勒一直有一个非常明确的想法，他想攻击西方。他想发动先发制人的打击。
He's obsessed with a sense of urgency. He knows that his enemies have never been weaker because the Soviet Union is bogged down in Finland. The United States has got presidential elections and is very unlikely to intervene. So this is his chance. His priority is Britain. He never wanted war with Britain in 1939. The whole point of this is to get them to negotiate. So he's been thinking about this for weeks and months.
他沉迷于一种紧迫感。他知道他的敌人从未如此虚弱，因为苏联深陷芬兰泥潭。美国正在进行总统选举，极不可能进行干预。所以这是他的机会。他的首要目标是英国。他从未想过在1939年与英国开战。这一切的重点是让他们进行谈判。所以他已经考虑这个问题好几周甚至好几个月了。
Even during the Norway campaign, he had been discussing this with Goebbels. So they'd had a long talk about this on the 21st of April in 1940. And Hitler said, you know, it's a shame in many ways we're fighting the British because they are our kind of racial cousins. But, you know, we knew that we'd have to do it at some point, probably in the next five years, so maybe it's better to do it now before the British are rearmed. The Goebbels wrote in his diary afterwards, the Fuhrer would make peace today. He doesn't want at all to annihilate England nor destroy its empire.
即使在挪威战役期间，他也一直在与戈培尔讨论这个问题。所以他们在1940年4月21日就此进行了长时间的交谈。希特勒说，你知道，在很多方面我们与英国人作战是一种耻辱，因为他们是我们种族上的表亲。但是，你知道，我们知道在某个时候我们必须这样做，可能是在未来五年内，所以也许现在做比等英国人重新武装起来要好。戈培尔后来在日记中写道，元首今天就会讲和。他根本不想消灭英国，也不想摧毁其帝国。
The condition, England out of Europe and our colleagues. is back to us, but that is only possible if it's already received a knockout blow. So it there is England? Yes. And the knockout blow is to beat France, what Goebbels calls, an act of historical justice against the French that will leave Britain friendless on the continent. So how are they going to do it? So if you look at the two sets of forces on paper, they're actually pretty well matched.
条件是，英国退出欧洲，我们的殖民地归还给我们，但这只有在它已经受到致命打击的情况下才有可能。所以英国在那里吗？是的。而致命一击就是打败法国，戈培尔称之为对法国人的一种历史正义，这将使英国在大陆上失去盟友。那么他们打算怎么做呢？所以如果你看看纸面上的两支军队，它们实际上匹配得相当好。
The French have more tanks. They have 3,000 tanks, the Germans 2,000. The French have much more artillery. The Germans have about 90 divisions, a division vary roughly, about 15,000 men. The French have got the same, and the British have got another 10 divisions, always much smaller on land, the British. But the Germans have got a couple of advantages. They've got slightly more fighters and bombers than the Allies do in the West, and they
法国人有更多的坦克。他们有3000辆坦克，德国人有2000辆。法国人有更多的火炮。德国人有大约90个师，一个师大约有15000人。法国人也有同样多的兵力，英国人还有另外10个师，英国人在陆地上的兵力总是少得多。但德国人有几个优势。他们的战斗机和轰炸机比盟军在西方的要多一点，而且他们
have learned in Poland how they can use them, they can use them in cooperation with their ground troops to full effect, which the British and French have not learned how to do. That is true that they do have some battle-hardened troops. However, because everyone knows what is going to come, and because Nazi propaganda has been harping on the ruthless, invincible, mechanised nature of the German war machine, and so the success of the Nazi troops in the invasion of France will kind of retrospectively burnish that propaganda. I said in my brother's book, The War in the West, he talks about this potent-in quality of Nazi militarism. So actually, overall, the Allies do have more planes
在波兰学会了如何使用它们，他们可以与地面部队充分配合，发挥出全部威力，而英法两国还没有学会如何做到这一点。确实，他们确实有一些久经沙场的部队。然而，因为每个人都知道即将发生什么，而且因为纳粹宣传一直在强调德国战争机器的无情、不可战胜和机械化本质，所以纳粹军队在入侵法国时的成功将会在事后美化这种宣传。我在我兄弟的书《西线战争》中说过，他谈到了纳粹军国主义的这种潜在品质。所以实际上，总的来说，盟军拥有的飞机比德国空军总体上要多。
between them than the Luftwaffe overall. And actually, the German troops, only half of all of them have had more than a few weeks training, more than a court at over 40. The artillery, the German artillery, is designed to be drawn by horses. And of the 135 divisions, that have been earmarked for the invasion of France. Of those, only 10 are panzer, and only six are fully mechanised. So the idea that the whole German army is kind of the cutting edge of modern fighting forces simply isn't true. I really hadn't properly appreciated that.
而且实际上，德国军队中只有一半的人接受过超过几周的训练，超过四分之一的人年龄在40岁以上。火炮，德国火炮，设计上是由马匹牵引的。在被指定用于入侵法国的135个师中，只有10个是装甲师，只有6个是完全机械化的。所以认为整个德国军队是现代作战部队的尖端力量的想法根本不是真的。我真的没有充分意识到这一点。
And I think it does kind of put the looming calamity for French and British arms into an even more sharper perspective, I think. They are not beaten by an overwhelmingly mechanised force. No, no, no, no, they're not at all. What I would say is the Germans do still win, though. So, I mean, we shouldn't go to the other extreme and suggest that they're completely useless. No, they're not. I mean, as we'll see, they have good tactics.
而且我认为这确实让法英军队即将面临的灾难变得更加清晰了。他们并不是被一支压倒性的机械化部队打败的。不，不，不，根本不是。我想说的是，德国人确实还是赢了。所以，我的意思是，我们不应该走向另一个极端，认为他们完全没用。不，他们不是。我的意思是，正如我们将看到的，他们有很好的战术。
But I think it also reflects on the grotesque incompetence of the Allies in the test that is to come. Well, I mean, we've talked about how incompetent the Allies were in Norway. Their planning and their intelligence in the Western campaign and this campaign are unbelievably useless. They seem to have no sense of how quickly armoured divisions can move. The French are always fighting the last war. It's mad that in the First World War, they were fighting the Franco-Opressional or the Napoleonic Wars. And now they think they're fighting the First World War. So they're all geared up for kind of trenches and all of that kind of thing.
但我认为这也反映了盟军在即将到来的考验中表现出的极其无能。嗯，我的意思是，我们已经谈到了盟军在挪威是多么无能。他们在西线战役和这次战役中的计划和情报简直是毫无用处。他们似乎根本不知道装甲师的移动速度有多快。法国人总是打上一场战争。疯狂的是，在第一次世界大战中，他们还在打普法战争或拿破仑战争。而现在他们认为他们还在打第一次世界大战。所以他们都为战壕战之类的东西做好了准备。
And it's as though tanks have not yet been invented. And actually, General Begon, who takes command of the French armies on the 25th of May, by which point it's obvious that France is completely defeated. He said, we've gone to war with a 1918 army against a German army of 1939, which in terms of equipment isn't true, but in terms of attitude is clearly the case. Yes, it is, absolutely. So let's get into a little bit of military strategy
就好像坦克还没有被发明出来一样。实际上，5月25日接管法国军队指挥权的贝当将军，当时法国显然已经彻底战败了。他说，我们用1918年的军队去打1939年的德国军队，这在装备上是不真实的，但在态度上显然是这样。是的，绝对是。所以让我们进入一点军事战略。
because an absolutely key French failure and British failure, they completely fail to predict the Germans' line of attack. So, as we saw last time, Hitler wanted to attack straight away in the autumn in 1939, but because it was a lot of dithering and mainly because the weather, that was postponed. And that has given the Germans time to refine their plans. So people who listened to our First World War series
因为一个绝对关键的法国和英国的失败是，他们完全没能预测到德国人的进攻路线。所以，正如我们上次看到的那样，希特勒想在1939年秋天立即发动进攻，但因为有很多犹豫不决，主要是因为天气原因，这被推迟了。这给了德国人时间来完善他们的计划。所以听过我们第一次世界大战系列节目的人
will have heard a lot about things like the Schlefen Plan and all the difficulties that the Germans faced in 1914. Their plan in 1939, 1914 was initially very similar. They would go through Belgium and Holland because they want to get around the Maginot Line, which are these forts the French were built to defend Alsace and Lorraine further south. The original German plan was to go through Belgium and Holland,
会听到很多关于施里芬计划以及德国人在1914年面临的所有困难的事情。他们在1939年、1914年的计划最初非常相似。他们会穿过比利时和荷兰，因为他们想绕过马奇诺防线，这是法国人为保卫更南边的阿尔萨斯和洛林而建造的堡垒。德国最初的计划是穿过比利时和荷兰，
very First World War, we push the French back to the Somme, And then we kind of grind them down there. And when that plan was presented to Hitler, he didn't like it. He said, I just think this feels very 1914. It's very unoriginal. Yeah, I want something, I want a decisive, exciting, original, you know, stroke, speed and surprise. That's what I'm all about. Now, meanwhile, two other generals, Eric von Manstein and a Panzer Commander Heinz Quderian,
非常第一次世界大战的风格，我们将法国人推回索姆河，然后我们在那里消耗他们。当那个计划提交给希特勒时，他不喜欢它。他说，我只是觉得这感觉非常像1914年。非常缺乏原创性。是的，我想要一些决定性的、令人兴奋的、原创的东西，你知道，速度和突然性。这就是我所追求的。现在，与此同时，另外两位将军，埃里希·冯·曼施坦因和装甲指挥官海因茨·古德里安，
had been working on a rival plan. And this plan, they said, look, why don't we just pretend effectively to go through Belgium and Holland, the low countries. Why don't we concentrate our tanks a little bit further south and go through the Ardennes forest? Because it's the forest, everybody assumes it's kind of off limits and the French will leave it only lightly defended. And the high command of the army, the Wehrmacht,
一直在制定一个竞争计划。他们说，看，为什么我们不假装穿过比利时和荷兰，即低地国家呢？为什么我们不把坦克稍微集中在南边一点，穿过阿登森林呢？因为它是森林，每个人都认为它是禁区，法国人只会对其进行轻微防御。而德国陆军最高统帅部，国防军，
thought this plan was deranged. And they basically sent Manstein to East Prussia to shut him up, to get rid of him. But one person who doesn't is Guderian. he two years before had written the most the most German army titled book of all time because its title was Actung Panzer exclamation mark that's sort of a British comic from the 1970s isn't it? It's such a great title and he's Hitler's kind of man. Yeah.
认为这个计划是疯狂的。他们基本上把曼施坦因送到了东普鲁士，让他闭嘴，把他打发走。但有一个人没有这样做，那就是古德里安。他两年前写了有史以来最具有德国军队风格的书，因为它的标题是《注意，坦克！》（Achtung Panzer!）。那听起来像是1970年代的英国漫画，不是吗？这是一个很棒的标题，他是希特勒那种人。是的。
Because he's all about speed, he's about the idea that you separate the panzers off from the much more cumbersome, slower-moving infantry divisions and the artillery with their horses and things. things, and you just go for broke, speed. So here's now a mad thing that happens, right? The High Command wants to go with their original plan, despite Hitler's misgivings. And then on the 10th of January, a Luftwaffe plane got lost in fog. It accidentally flies into Belgium, and it crashes in a field in Belgium.
因为他追求的是速度，他追求的是将装甲部队与更笨重、移动缓慢的步兵师以及带着马匹的炮兵分离开来的想法，然后你就孤注一掷，追求速度。现在发生了一件疯狂的事情，对吧？最高统帅部想坚持他们最初的计划，尽管希特勒有疑虑。然后1月10日，一架德国空军飞机在雾中迷路了。它意外地飞进了比利时，并在比利时的一个田野里坠毁了。
And the passenger on the plane is called Major Reinhberger, and he is carrying the plan. And after the crash, the pilot and this bloke, Major Reimberg, were picked up by a Belgian border guards who took them to a sort of hut. Don't forget, Belgium is neutral at this stage. Major Reinhberger tried to destroy their plans by stuffing them into a stove when the Belgian border guards backs were turned. I think he madly burnt his hands in the process
飞机上的乘客叫莱因伯格少校，他带着计划。坠机后，飞行员和这个叫莱因伯格少校的家伙被比利时边防警卫抓住了，他们把他们带到了一个小屋里。别忘了，比利时在这个阶段是中立的。当比利时边防警卫转过身时，莱因伯格少校试图通过把计划塞进火炉里来销毁它们。我想他在这个过程中疯狂地烧伤了自己的手，
trying to get the lid off the stove. Anyway, the border guards managed to get the plans back out of the stove. Major Reimberger at this point burst into tears and tried to shoot himself. Anyway, the upshot was the Allies say, oh, brilliant, we've got the German plan. So we know for sure they're going to come through Belgium and Holland, just as we thought. Brilliant.
试图把火炉的盖子打开。总之，边防警卫设法把计划从火炉里拿了出来。莱因伯格少校此时泪流满面，试图自杀。总之，结果是盟军说，哦，太棒了，我们拿到了德国人的计划。所以我们确定他们会穿过比利时和荷兰，正如我们所想的那样。太棒了。
We're laughing. So actually, it's like all those Allied plans to deceive the Germans about where D-Day Landing is going to happen. Yeah, it is. Only they haven't actually fabricated it in this case. Exactly. Now, in the meantime, the problem for the Allies, the Germans have changed their entire plan. Hitler never liked that blueprint anyway. He liked the idea of a surprise attack through the Ardennes as well.
我们赢定了。所以实际上，这就像所有那些盟军为了欺骗德国人关于诺曼底登陆地点而制定的计划一样。是的，确实。只是在这种情况下，他们并没有编造它。没错。现在，与此同时，盟军的问题是，德国人已经改变了他们的整个计划。希特勒本来就不喜欢那个蓝图。他也喜欢通过阿登森林进行突然袭击的想法。
And on the 17th of February, so a month after this crash, his agitlam. His adjutant invited Manstein to the Reich Chancellery. It actually said to him, come on, come and tell the fewer about this mad idea of yours. He'll love it. And Hitler doesn't like Manstein. Manstein's a very kind of cold, arrogant, Prussian aristocrats, the kind of person he's always distrustful of. But he listens to the plan. He says, I've been gagging to hear a plan like this.
2月17日，也就是这次坠机事件一个月后，他的副官邀请曼施坦因到帝国总理府。实际上对他说，来吧，来告诉元首你这个疯狂的想法。他会喜欢的。希特勒不喜欢曼施坦因。曼施坦因是一个非常冷漠、傲慢的普鲁士贵族，是他一直不信任的那种人。但他听了这个计划。他说，我一直渴望听到这样的计划。
Through the Ardennes, surprise attack, reckless. I love it. I love the sound of it. Let's go for it. Brilliant. So this becomes the blueprint for Falgelb, case yellow, the German operation in the West. Basically, there are two army groups. Army Group B is under Fedor von Bok.
穿过阿登森林，突然袭击，鲁莽。我喜欢它。我喜欢听起来的感觉。让我们去做吧。太棒了。所以这成为了“黄色方案”（Fall Gelb）的蓝图，即德国在西方的行动。基本上，有两个集团军群。B集团军群由费多尔·冯·博克指挥。
How large is the other two army groups? So Army Group B is 29 divisions, Tom. So how many men is that? Well, it's 15,000 men. You can do the maths yourself. Could you? Yeah, but I just don't want to. I'd like to give you a bit of a workout.
另外两个集团军群有多大？所以B集团军群有29个师，汤姆。那是多少人？嗯，是15000人。你自己算算吧。你能吗？是的，但我只是不想算。我想让你锻炼一下。
So anyway, they've got 29 divisions, 15,000 men each. Listeners can do the math, they will go through Belgium and Holland. But this is a massive distraction exercise, because the real action is going to come further south with Gert von Rundstedt's Army Group A. And Army Group A has 44 divisions with loads of panzers and mechanized infantry, and they are going to sneak through the woods of the Ardennes, and then this is the plan. When they're across, they'll get to the river Murs, and they'll cross the Murs. But at that point, they won't carry on towards Paris.
总之，他们有29个师，每个师15000人。听众可以自己算算，他们将穿过比利时和荷兰。但这只是一个巨大的分散注意力的演习，因为真正的行动将在南边由格特·冯·伦德施泰特的A集团军群进行。A集团军群有44个师，配备了大量的装甲部队和机械化步兵，他们将潜入阿登森林，这就是计划。当他们穿过森林后，他们会到达默兹河，并渡过默兹河。但在那一点上，他们不会继续向巴黎进军，
as the Allies will expect, they will turn sharply to their right, in other words, turning north, and they will head up towards the coast of the English Channel in a kind of what's called a sickle-cut manoeuvre. And what that means is that all the allied French and British forces in Belgium will be trapped between the two German armies, and they'll be pinned against the sea. And so this is the Battle of Can I, you know, the great victory, that Hannibal won over the Romans. which have haunted, haunted the German military planning. And so in a sense, although this seems tactically radical, strategically, it is what the Germans, is what they always come up with.
正如盟军所预期的那样，他们会向右急转，换句话说，向北转，他们将以一种所谓的“镰刀收割”机动方式向英吉利海峡海岸进军。这意味着所有在比利时的盟军法英部队都将被困在两支德国军队之间，他们将被钉在海边。所以这就是坎尼战役，你知道，汉尼拔战胜罗马人的伟大胜利，这一直困扰着德国的军事规划。所以从某种意义上说，虽然这看起来在战术上很激进，但在战略上，这就是德国人一直想出来的东西。
And so that being so, you would think the French would have realized it. I mean, it's just so mind-blowingly incompetent that they haven't sussed this out. I'll make two observations. Number one is, I don't think there's ever been a battle on the rest of its history that you haven't likened to the Battle of Can I? So that's the first point. Listen, it's not me who's doing it. It's the German High Command.
既然如此，你可能会认为法国人会意识到这一点。我的意思是，他们没有发现这一点简直是令人难以置信的无能。我会观察两点。第一点是，我不认为在“历史的其余部分”中还有哪场战斗你没有将其比作坎尼战役。所以这是第一点。听着，不是我在做这件事。是德国最高统帅部。
They are always doing it. They always want to fight the Battle of Can I. And secondly, the reason I think the French have not anticipated this, and nobody has anticipated this, is because this is not an operation that would have been possible in the First World War when you moved so much more slowly. It's only really possible because your panzers are game changers. They can move so quickly.
他们一直在做这件事。他们总是想打坎尼战役。其次，我认为法国人没有预料到这一点的原因，也是没有人预料到这一点的原因，是因为这不是第一次世界大战中可能进行的行动，当时你的移动速度要慢得多。这只有在你的装甲部队是游戏规则改变者时才真正可能。他们可以移动得如此之快。
They can punch through an enemy line and get around you before you even know it. But Guderian, who they know is in command, has written up this in Akhtung Panzer. So why haven't they read it? It's hopeless. They haven't done your level of research, or your brother's level of research, I should say. Clearly.
他们可以在你甚至不知道之前就突破敌人的防线并绕过你。但古德里安，他们知道他是指挥官，已经在《注意，坦克！》中写到了这一点。所以他们为什么没读过它？没救了。他们没有做你那个水平的研究，或者说你兄弟那个水平的研究。显然。
I mean, tell me you, look actually personally aggrieved that the French haven't been doing the reading. Well, reading the War in the West, my brother's book, and listening to episodes on this in We Have Ways, his podcast, I am left, you know, kind of stupefied by how hopeless the French are on this. And, you know, the British complicit in as well.
我的意思是，告诉我，你看起来实际上对法国人没有阅读感到委屈。嗯，读了《西线战争》，我兄弟的书，并听了他在他的播客《我们有办法》（We Have Ways）中关于这个话题的剧集，我感到目瞪口呆，法国人在这一点上是多么无望。而且，你知道，英国人也参与其中。
because they're not pointing it out either. No, it's poor from the British. All right, so the date of the invasion was set for the early hours at Friday, the 10th of May, as we've seen. When the news broke in Berlin, the mood in Germany was very glum. So in his diary, the American journalist,
因为他们也没有指出这一点。不，英国人的表现很差。好吧，所以入侵日期定在5月10日星期五的凌晨，正如我们所见。当消息在柏林传开时，德国的气氛非常阴郁。所以在美国记者的日记里，
William Lschirer, notes there's no crowds on the streets and the people that he meets seem sunk in depression because they think they're going to lose, you see? Now, Hitler, it is rock-eary, the fell as a nest. He is very calm and confident. And he says to his entourage,
威廉·夏伊勒（William L. Shirer）指出街上没有人群，他遇到的人似乎沉浸在沮丧中，因为他们认为他们会输，你明白吗？现在，希特勒，在“野战巢”，他非常冷静和自信。他对随从说，
I think we'll beat France in six weeks. And then we'll find the British coming to talk to us because they want to save their empire. So he's right about one of those prophecies and wrong about the second. Right. And actually, as the first reports kind of come into the Rock Erie, his optimism seems very well founded. So to begin with the low countries, at half four that morning, the German paratroopers and special forces had begun their operation.
我想我们会在六周内打败法国。然后我们会发现英国人来找我们谈话，因为他们想拯救他们的帝国。所以他预言对了一个，预言错了第二个。对。而且实际上，当第一批报告传到“野战巢”时，他的乐观似乎非常有根据。所以首先是低地国家，那天凌晨四点半，德国伞兵和特种部队开始了他们的行动。
They'd been dropped by gliders and things. They'd seized the key bridges and forts on the German and Dutch borders. By mid-morning, so within hours, the Dutch are falling back to the north, and the German tanks are rolling through the fields of Holland. And the Dutch have no tanks, but they do have people on bicycles. They do, but they're not very useful, as we will find out. Now, the Allies have responded to this very sluggishly. The French had heard rumors of a murmuring in the German lines a couple of days before,
他们被滑翔机等运送。他们占领了德国和荷兰边境的关键桥梁和堡垒。到上午中期，也就是几个小时内，荷兰人向北撤退，德国坦克在荷兰的田野里滚动。荷兰人没有坦克，但他们有骑自行车的人。他们确实有，但正如我们将发现的那样，他们没什么用。现在，盟军对此反应非常迟钝。法国人在几天前就听到了德国防线有动静的传闻，
but their commander said, well, there's always murmuring from the Germans. It's probably a false alarm. The Allied commander in chief is a Frenchman, of course, because the French by far the biggest troop contingent. He is General Maurice Gamalach. And he's a very, I think he's a very likable man in anyways, Gamalin. He's kind of jaunty and jolly. He loves art. He loves philosophy.
但他们的指挥官说，嗯，德国人总是有动静。这可能是一个虚惊。盟军总司令当然是法国人，因为法国人是兵力最多的部队。他是莫里斯·甘末林将军。我认为甘末林在很多方面是一个非常讨人喜欢的人。他有点轻快和快乐。他热爱艺术。他热爱哲学。
He had been the protege of our old friend, General Jophe, from 1914. Oh, yes. Loves a long lunch. Yeah. Long lunching. And imperturbable, isn't he? and imperturbable, right? And Gamalan has completely cut from the same cloth.
他是我们1914年的老朋友霞飞将军的门生。哦，是的。喜欢吃长午餐。是的。长午餐。而且泰然自若，不是吗？而且泰然自若，对吧？甘末林完全是同一类人。
He says, listen, what I've learned from Joff is you never lose your call. Things will probably be fine. Don't overthink anything. You know, it'll be a long war. Let's not stress about it. The Germans attack, we shall advance calmly into Belgium to meet them. Of course, he doesn't know they're not going to come really through Belgium. So right from the start, the Allies are walking into the Germans trap,
他说，听着，我从霞飞那里学到的是，你永远不要失去冷静。事情可能会好起来的。不要过度思考任何事情。你知道，这将是一场漫长的战争。我们不要为此感到压力。德国人进攻，我们将冷静地进入比利时去迎接他们。当然，他不知道他们真的不会穿过比利时。所以从一开始，盟军就走进了德国人的陷阱，
just as Manstein and Hitler had dreamed. Within four and a half days, the Germans have wiped the floor with the Dutch. The climax coming on the 14th when the Luftwaffe bombed Rotterdam and they destroyed the old city of Rotterdam, a massive story at the time. Yeah, apparently this was a mistake. Yeah. Because the Dutch had already begun negotiating their surrender. That's right.
正如曼施坦因和希特勒所梦想的那样。在四天半内，德国人就横扫了荷兰。高潮出现在14日，当时德国空军轰炸了鹿特丹，他们摧毁了鹿特丹的老城区，这在当时是一个巨大的新闻。是的，显然这是一个错误。是的。因为荷兰人已经开始谈判投降了。没错。
And so the orders went out to the bombers, you know, don't do it. But it was too late. The bombers had already left. And so they, you know, as they say, they obliterate it. And actually, I mean, it works incredibly well for the Nazis, doesn't it? Because it, again, it compounds this sense that there can be no opposition, that they are lethal. And they have the stucas, they kind of have a siren, don't they? So that when they drop, this terrifying kind of scream.
所以命令下达给轰炸机，你知道，不要这样做。但已经太晚了。轰炸机已经出发了。所以他们，正如他们所说，他们将其夷为平地。而且实际上，我的意思是，这对纳粹来说效果非常好，不是吗？因为它再次加剧了这种感觉，即不可能有任何反对，他们是致命的。他们有斯图卡轰炸机，它们有一种警报器，不是吗？所以当它们俯冲时，这种可怕的尖叫声。
And the whole thing is just, you know, this sense that there is no resisting the Nazi war machine. Exactly. Even though, you know, it is quite an element of smoke and mirrors about it. Well, in the case of Rotterdam, a lot of smoke. Well, if you think the evasion starts on the 10th of May and what it must have been like to live through the next couple of weeks, even if you're just following events in the newspapers, the sense of growing inevitability, of relentlessness and speed about the German advance.
整个事情就是，你知道，这种感觉，即没有办法抵抗纳粹战争机器。没错。尽管，你知道，它确实有相当多的烟雾和镜子成分。嗯，在鹿特丹的案例中，有很多烟雾。嗯，如果你认为入侵始于5月10日，那么经历接下来的几周会是什么样子，即使你只是在报纸上关注事件，那种不断增长的必然性，德国人推进的速度和无情。
So the Dutch surrender, four and a half days, the Queen Villalmina and her ministers escaped to London to become a government in exile. The Belgians held out for 18 days, but they too were overwhelmed by sheer weight of numbers and firepower. Interestingly, the Belgian king did not flee his country. He had taken personal command of the army and he said, I don't want to desert them, I should stay.
所以荷兰投降了，四天半，威廉明娜女王和她的部长们逃往伦敦成为流亡政府。比利时人坚持了18天，但他们也被绝对的人数和火力优势所压倒。有趣的是，比利时国王没有逃离他的国家。他亲自指挥军队，他说，我不想抛弃他们，我应该留下来。
So he stays in Brussels. He becomes a prisoner of the Germans, and he was painted by the Allied press as a traitor. The Mirror, Daily Mirror, ran the headline about him. I think a headline that no man wishes to read about himself, the face that every woman now despises. What's the basis for that contempt? I mean, it seems courageous that a commander-in-chief should stand. He was seen as a collaborator, and actually the Belgians got rid of him after the war. they saw him as tainted because he had not made the gestures of moral defiance, I guess,
所以他留在布鲁塞尔。他成为了德国人的囚犯，他被盟军媒体描绘成叛徒。《每日镜报》刊登了关于他的头条新闻。我想这是一个男人不希望读到关于自己的头条新闻，“每个女人现在都鄙视的面孔”。这种蔑视的基础是什么？我的意思是，总司令应该站出来似乎是勇敢的。他被视为合作者，实际上战后比利时人摆脱了他。他们认为他被玷污了，因为他没有做出道德反抗的姿态，我想，
that King Christian had done in Denmark. Right, I see. Okay. I think King Leopold had taken a very different approach. Right. So within three weeks, both Holland and Belgium are under German military occupation where they will remain for the next five years. But of course, this isn't where the main action is happening.
就像克里斯蒂安国王在丹麦所做的那样。对，我明白了。好的。我想利奥波德国王采取了非常不同的方法。对。所以三周内，荷兰和比利时都处于德国军事占领之下，他们将在那里停留五年。但当然，这不是主要行动发生的地方。
This really is smoke and mirrors because the real action for the Germans is happening further south than the Arden Forest. And here, you wanted numbers, Tom. Now, secretly, while I was talking, I was doing the map. So here, General von Klaist, because I'm multitasking, he's leading 134,000 soldiers, 1,200 tanks and 500 armored vehicles through the kind of narrow roads that lead through the Ardennes forest. And this means surely that they are now sitting ducks if the French Air Force attacks them. Totally.
这确实是烟雾和镜子，因为德国人的真正行动发生在更南边的阿登森林。在这里，你想要数字，汤姆。现在，秘密地，当我说话时，我正在算数。所以在这里，克莱斯特将军，因为我正在多任务处理，他正带领134000名士兵、1200辆坦克和500辆装甲车穿过通往阿登森林的狭窄道路。这意味着如果法国空军攻击他们，他们肯定会成为活靶子。完全是。
Because there are only very few roads, they're quite narrow, long tailbacks. You know where they are? send the French planes in, but the French don't. Yeah. It's very like when, you know, when Putin attacked Ukraine, that huge traffic jam, as they were outside Kiev of kind of Russian tanks or whatever, it's the same story. The Germans said at the time, it's the longest traffic jam in history, is four columns, hundreds of miles long.
因为只有很少的道路，它们相当狭窄，长长的尾巴。你知道它们在哪里吗？派法国飞机去，但法国人没有。是的。这很像普京攻击乌克兰时，基辅外那场巨大的交通堵塞，俄罗斯坦克什么的，这是同一个故事。德国人在当时说，这是历史上最长的交通堵塞，有四列，长达数百英里。
There's tanks, yes, and there's armoured cars, but there are wagons and there are horses and there are, you know, lines of troops. Because if the French Air Force had gone in, the war would have been over. But they didn't. And the Germans know it, right? So the Germans are in a great hurry. They are told you can't stop for three days, and they're issued with amphetamines to keep going.
有坦克，是的，有装甲车，但有马车，有马，有，你知道，一排排的部队。因为如果法国空军去了，战争就结束了。但他们没有。德国人知道这一点，对吧？所以德国人非常匆忙。他们被告知你不能停下来三天，他们被发了安非他命以继续前进。
You just have to keep going for three days. Can't stop. But after three days, on the afternoon in the 12th of May, they have reached the river Murs, their objective, without having been destroyed from above by the French. Now, when they get to the river, this is a crucial moment. If the French can hold them back at the river, then the sickle-cut scheme will have failed. But we said before, the Germans are much better than. are using air power in tandem with ground troops
你只需要坚持三天。不能停。但在三天后，5月12日下午，他们到达了默兹河，他们的目标，而没有被法国人从空中摧毁。现在，当他们到达河边时，这是一个关键时刻。如果法国人能把他们挡在河边，那么“镰刀收割”计划就会失败。但我们之前说过，德国人比他们强得多。在使用空中力量与地面部队配合方面
because the Germans have learned how to do it in Poland. The next day, General von Klaist calls up a thousand planes and they pound the French positions. For the French, who of course have not been through the experience of the war in Poland, this is a colossal shock. It's the first time they've come under air attack. And there are all these stories about their troops sort of cowering in their trenches, sobbing, traumatized, you know, their morale.
因为德国人在波兰学会了如何做到这一点。第二天，克莱斯特将军召集了一千架飞机，他们猛烈轰炸了法国人的阵地。对于当然没有经历过波兰战争的法国人来说，这是一个巨大的冲击。这是他们第一次受到空袭。而且有所有关于他们的部队在战壕里畏缩、啜泣、受创伤的故事，你知道，他们的士气。
ripped to pieces. And so by the evening of the 13th, so remember, we're just three or four days into the invasion, the Germans are already crossing the river on rubber dinghies, they're putting together pontoon bridges, the panzers are getting across. They're still quite vulnerable.
被撕成了碎片。所以到了13日晚上，所以记住，我们才入侵三四天，德国人已经乘着橡皮艇过河了，他们正在组装浮桥，装甲部队正在过河。他们仍然相当脆弱。
You know, they're still vulnerable to a counterattack, but the amazing thing the French are still so complacent. The commander of their second army was General Charles Antiguerre. And General Antiguerre is told the Germans are getting across the river Murs, and he says,
你知道，他们仍然容易受到反击，但令人惊奇的是法国人仍然如此自满。他们的第二军指挥官是查尔斯·安蒂格将军。安蒂格将军被告知德国人正在渡过默兹河，他说，
brilliant. All the more prisoners for us. And presumably General Gamalais is emulating General Joffre and just sitting around having huge lunches and munching on chickens and things. I think there is an element of that. We'll have some amusing French military action of this kind, a bit with an omelette, which is good for them. So the next couple of days, things go from bad to worse for the French. They finally decide to launch a counterattack on the MERS, but it's half-hearted. They don't dislodge the Germans. They take very heavy losses.
太棒了。我们会有更多的俘虏。据推测，甘末林将军正在效仿霞飞将军，只是坐在那里吃着丰盛的午餐，嚼着鸡肉之类的东西。我想确实有这种成分。我们将会有一些这种有趣的法国军事行动，带点煎蛋卷，这对他们有好处。所以接下来的几天，法国人的情况变得越来越糟。他们终于决定对默兹河发动反击，但这是半心半意的。他们没有赶走德国人。他们损失惨重。
And unlike in 1914, their nerve begins to break quite early on. So that night, the 14th, there were reports of French troops streaming westwards in a panic, shouting, we've lost, we've been betrayed and so on. And at their headquarters, their commanders are just completely stunned. They didn't expect the Germans to come through the Ardenne, and they didn't expect them to come in such speed or in such numbers. They didn't expect them to get across the river Meuse. and now they make another catastrophic mistake. They think, now the Germans have got across the MERS, they will head towards Paris. But they won't.
与1914年不同，他们的意志很快就开始动摇。因此，在14日那天晚上，有报道称法军在恐慌中向西溃逃，高喊着“我们输了”、“我们被出卖了”等等。在指挥部里，指挥官们完全惊呆了。他们没料到德军会穿过阿登地区，也没料到德军推进的速度如此之快、人数如此之多。他们没料到德军能渡过默兹河。现在，他们又犯了一个灾难性的错误。他们认为，既然德军已经渡过了默兹河，他们就会向巴黎进军。但他们不会。
They're going to turn sharp right at this point, turn north, and race for the channel. This is the sickle-cut element of the plan, which will leave the Allied armies trapped. And what is worse? As the French and the British are trying to react, Eastern France has descended into complete chaos, because remembering what happened in the First World War, and having read the reports of what happened in Poland, millions, literally millions of civilians say, God, I've got to get out of here.
他们会在这一点上急转弯，转向北方，直奔海峡。这就是计划中“镰刀收割”的部分，它将使盟军陷入困境。更糟糕的是，当英法联军试图做出反应时，法国东部已经陷入了彻底的混乱，因为人们还记得第一次世界大战中发生的事情，也读过关于波兰遭遇的报道，数以百万计的平民都在说：“天哪，我必须离开这里。”
And they take to the streets. So by this point, we're feeling to kind of mid-May, 1940, there were probably about eight million people on the roads of France with their possessions with wagons, with bicycles, with livestock, you know, crying babies, all of that. And that makes it impossible for the French to move their armies around, you know, their communications networks are kind of breaking down, all of this. And then the Stuccas start dive bombing the crowds of refugees. So more terror. Total carnage. You know, a sense that these are just implacable opponents who can't be defeated. Yeah.
于是他们涌上街头。到1940年5月中旬，法国公路上可能有大约八百万人在逃难，带着他们的财物、马车、自行车、牲畜，还有哭闹的婴儿等等。这使得法军无法调动军队，他们的通讯网络也随之瘫痪。接着，斯图卡轰炸机开始俯冲轰炸难民群。更多的恐怖，彻底的屠杀。人们感到这些对手是不可战胜的，是冷酷无情的。
Now, remember how quickly this has happened. Invasion began in the early hours of the 10th of May. On the 15th of May, so five days later at 7.30 in the morning, Winston Churchill, who's only, been Prime Minister for five days, is woken up at home by a phone call from Paul Reno. And Rayno speaks to him in English, and Rayno says, we have been defeated. And Churchill doesn't say anything. And Rayno says again, we are beaten. We have lost the battle. Churchill, surely it can't have happened so soon, but he replied, the front is broken near Sedon. Cedon is exactly where they'd lost the Franco-Prussian war in 1870. So the next afternoon, 16th, Churchill
现在，请记住这一切发生得有多快。入侵始于5月10日凌晨。5月15日，也就是五天后的早上7点30分，刚上任五天的温斯顿·丘吉尔在家里被保罗·雷诺的电话吵醒。雷诺用英语对他说：“我们被打败了。”丘吉尔没有说话。雷诺又说：“我们被击溃了。我们输掉了这场战役。”丘吉尔简直不敢相信这一切发生得如此之快，但他回答说：“前线在色当附近被突破了。”色当正是他们在1870年普法战争中战败的地方。所以第二天下午，即16日，丘吉尔
flies to Paris, and he is shocked when he gets there. They are burning their archives already there, preparing to evacuate the city. Utter dejection was written on every face. And General Gamelan is there. Gamelan says, not only have we taken this defeat at Sedan, but we have actually fallen back a further 60 kilometres. The Germans have come 60 kilometres since we last spoke. Churchill says this very famous exchange,
飞往巴黎，到达后他感到震惊。他们已经在焚烧档案，准备撤离这座城市。每个人的脸上都写满了彻底的沮丧。甘末林将军也在那里。甘末林说，我们不仅在色当遭遇了失败，而且实际上又后撤了60公里。自我们上次通话以来，德军已经推进了60公里。丘吉尔说了那段非常著名的话，
Where is your strategic reserve? And Gamelan says, Ogun, there isn't any. Churchill, why don't you counterattack? And then Gamalin gives a hopeless shrug of the shoulders and says to him, inferiority of numbers, inferiority of equipment, inferiority of method. Gamalans clearly got to go. I mean, the third of those is definitely right.
“你的战略预备队在哪里？”甘末林回答说：“没有，根本没有。”丘吉尔问：“为什么不反击？”甘末林无奈地耸了耸肩，对他说：“兵力不足，装备不足，战术落后。”甘末林显然必须下台。我的意思是，这三点中最后一点绝对是正确的。
Yeah. But the first two, at the beginning of the war, we're not right, yeah. So three days later, on the 19th, Rayno sacked Gamalat, and he replaced him with General Vagant, Maxim Vagin, who is a very very, Veteran of the First World War, who was 73 and who has been retired for the last five years. Does he, by any chance, have emphysema? It's not the First World War anymore, so maybe not. I don't know.
是的。但前两点，在战争初期，并不准确。所以三天后的19日，雷诺解雇了甘末林，由马克西姆·魏刚将军接替。他是一位非常资深的一战老兵，已经73岁，退休五年了。他会不会碰巧患有肺气肿？现在已经不是第一次世界大战了，所以也许没有。我不知道。
Vagant, he's got all these schemes for a great counterattack, a French counterattack. But by now, I think the Allies are in such chaos that any counterattack is going to be very, very difficult. The Germans, meanwhile, are rolling on. They cannot believe how well this is going. I mean, even in their wildest dreams, Manstein and Guderian could not have imagined the allies would fall apart so quickly. And a famous name in command of one of the Panzer divisions, Erwin Rommel. Yeah, Irwin Rommel, who will be featuring in due course later on in this story. Yes.
魏刚有一套关于大反攻的计划，法军的大反攻。但到目前为止，我认为盟军已经陷入了如此混乱，任何反攻都将非常非常困难。与此同时，德军势如破竹。他们简直不敢相信进展如此顺利。我的意思是，即使在最狂野的梦中，曼施坦因和古德里安也不敢想象盟军会如此迅速地崩溃。其中一个装甲师的指挥官是一个著名的名字，埃尔温·隆美尔。是的，埃尔温·隆美尔，他将在本故事的后续部分中出现。是的。
So on the night of the 19th, you began, Tom, this episode with Churchill broadcasting for the first time to the British people after nine days as Prime Minister. That night, the first panzers reached the mouth of the River Somme on the channel. And by the following note, they'd established themselves on the Channel Coast properly. So at this point, the sickle cut has been carried off. The entire Allied force in Belgium, that's three French armies. It's the shattered remains of the Belgian army and the entire British expeditionary force. They are all encircled and surrounded, trapped against the sea, in this shrinking pocket. And now, you know, if the French and British commanders were in a bit of a state before,
所以19日晚上，汤姆，你以丘吉尔担任首相九天后首次向英国人民发表广播讲话开始了这一集。那天晚上，第一批装甲部队到达了海峡边的索姆河口。到第二天晚上，他们已经在海峡沿岸站稳了脚跟。至此，“镰刀收割”计划已经完成。在比利时的整个盟军部队，包括三支法国军队、比利时军队的残部以及整个英国远征军，都被包围了，困在海边这个不断缩小的口袋里。现在，如果说英法指挥官之前还有点慌乱，
are in an absolute world-class funk. That's the word. Yeah, it is the word. The French commander in Belgium is General Gaston-Hourri-Bilotte. When he was told, you need to coordinate the Allied response to all this, he burst into tears, which I don't think is ever a good sign in your commanding officer. That's not what you want. On the 20th of May, so that's the day the Allies are definitively cut off. The British sent the chief of their Imperial General Staffs, Edmund Ironside, to launch.
现在他们简直陷入了世界级的恐慌。就是这个词。是的，就是这个词。驻比利时的法军指挥官是加斯顿·亨利·比约特将军。当他被告知需要协调盟军的应对措施时，他竟然泪流满面，我认为这对于指挥官来说绝不是什么好兆头。这不是你想要的。5月20日，也就是盟军被彻底切断的那一天，英国派出了帝国总参谋长埃德蒙·艾恩赛德去劳恩。
That is a great name. Yeah, you've got to be called that. Good for him. So General Ironside is sent to launch to see Billot to find out what's going on. And Ironside said later, I found him in a state of complete depression. No plan, no thought of a plan, ready to be slaughtered. I lost my temper and shook Bilot by the button of his tunic. The man is completely beaten.
那是个很棒的名字。是的，你得叫这个名字。对他来说很好。所以艾恩赛德将军被派往劳恩去见比约特，看看发生了什么。艾恩赛德后来写道：“我发现他处于完全沮丧的状态。没有计划，没有计划的想法，准备被屠杀。我发了火，抓着比约特的军服扣子摇晃他。这个人彻底被打垮了。”
So the next day, I promised you an omelette, the next day is the 21st of May. General Vagin, a new French Supreme Commander, decided to visit Bilot personally to steady his nerve. and he flew to a place called Betune on the Franco-Belgian border. Vagon got there. He finds the airfield completely deserted. There's just a single soldier. And Vagon has to persuade the soldier to give him a lift to the local post office. And there he finally managed to ring Bilot and said, send a car.
所以第二天，我答应过你一个煎蛋卷，第二天是5月21日。新任法军最高统帅魏刚将军决定亲自拜访比约特以稳定他的情绪。他飞往法比边境一个叫贝蒂讷的地方。魏刚到了那里，发现机场空无一人。只有一个士兵。魏刚不得不说服那个士兵载他去当地的邮局。在那里，他终于设法给比约特打了电话，说：“派辆车来。”
Like, I'm General Vagong. I'm the Supreme Commander. Send a car and get me. A car arrived. Vagong got in the car and he said, I need lunch. Like, let's go and have omelets. He went for an omelet. Then he went and met Bilot at Ypres Town Hall.
就像是，“我是魏刚将军。我是最高统帅。派辆车来接我。”车到了。魏刚上了车，说：“我要吃午饭。”就像是，“我们去吃煎蛋卷吧。”他去吃了煎蛋卷。然后他去伊普尔市政厅见了比约特。
I mean, talk about a place with a lot of history. And Vagon said, come on, we've got a counterattack. Like, we've got to break out, counterattack, whatever. Belot said fine. Bilot drove off. His car immediately got involved in a massive car crash. Bilot was badly injured, fell into a coma. Two days later, he died.
我的意思是，谈论一个历史悠久的地方。魏刚说：“来吧，我们得反击。我们得突围，反击，什么的。”比约特说好。比约特开车离开。他的车随即卷入了一场严重的车祸。比约特受了重伤，陷入昏迷。两天后，他去世了。
And that was the end of him. Do you know what, the British Expeditionary Forces, Chief of Staff, Sir Henry Pownall, or he mourned General Billot. What did he say? He said, frankly, he's no loss. I mean, it's harsh, but it's not inaccurate. Yeah. So, Hitler's attack has been unfolding now.
那就是他的结局。你知道吗，英国远征军参谋长亨利·鲍纳尔爵士，他哀悼了比约特将军。他说什么？他说：“坦率地说，他没什么损失。”我的意思是，这很刻薄，但并非不准确。是的。所以，希特勒的进攻现在已经展开了。
Less than two weeks. Insane. So actually, it's going better than Hitler had said. Than even Hitler had said. Because he'd prophesied it would take six weeks, right? And already by two weeks, it's clear he's won. He's been going on for like 11 days or something. And it's pretty clear that the Allies have collapsed, exactly.
不到两周。太疯狂了。实际上，进展比希特勒预想的还要好。比希特勒预想的还要好。因为他曾预言需要六周，对吧？仅仅两周时间，很明显他已经赢了。已经进行了大约11天左右。很明显盟军已经崩溃了，确实如此。
The amazing thing, I mean, he's this man who has gambled, gambled again and again, each one bigger and more ambitious and more reckless than the last and this one is going to work out better than any of them. The Allies have completely fallen apart. Their commanders aren't speaking to each other. Rayneau and his ministers are preparing to flee Paris.
令人惊奇的是，我的意思是，他是一个赌徒，一次又一次地赌博，每一次都比上一次更大、更雄心勃勃、更鲁莽，而这一次的结果比以往任何一次都要好。盟军已经彻底瓦解。他们的指挥官互不沟通。雷诺和他的部长们正准备逃离巴黎。
Surely France is beaten. The entire British expeditionary force 400,000 men are trapped in this pocket against the channel. The panzers are closing in on the channel ports of Boulogne, Kale and Dunker. Surely within days, Hitler's tanks will finish the job and then Britain will be forced to sue for peace.
法国肯定被打败了。整个英国远征军40万大军被困在海峡边的这个口袋里。装甲部队正在向布洛涅、加来和敦刻尔克的港口逼近。肯定不出几天，希特勒的坦克就会完成任务，然后英国将被迫求和。
Or Dominic, will Britain be forced to sue for peace? We will find out in our next two episodes to come on this series, The Miracle of Dunkirk, the fall of France, the Battle of Britain and in the long run, Hitler's decision to turn on the Soviet Union and members of the rest of history, Club can hear the next two episodes right now. And if you want to join them, go to the rest ishistory.com. But for now, thank you for listening. Thank you, Dominic. And au revoir. Avoire. Throughout time, celebration has meant giving. So the Romans at Saturnalia, handed out all kinds of gifts. The three magi handed out gold, frankincense and myrrh, and the Victorians absolutely loved wrapping things up in paper and then tying it up in string.
或者多米尼克，英国会被迫求和吗？我们将在本系列的接下来的两集中找到答案，敦刻尔克奇迹、法国沦陷、不列颠战役，以及从长远来看，希特勒决定转向苏联，而“历史其余部分”俱乐部的成员现在就可以收听接下来的两集。如果你想加入他们，请访问therestis-history.com。但现在，感谢收听。谢谢你，多米尼克。再见。再见。纵观历史，庆祝意味着给予。所以罗马人在农神节上分发各种礼物。三位智者分发了黄金、乳香和没药，维多利亚时代的人非常喜欢用纸把东西包起来，然后用绳子系好。
Some of those are lovely gestures, but I wonder if they're a little bit too extravagant for the typical Christmas morning. So this year, here's my suggestion to our listeners and our viewers, why not give something a little bit more enlightened? Why not give the gift of the rest is history club membership. It's the discerning choice for anybody who prefers a Hannibal to a hamper. It's ad-free listening. You get a weekly bonus episode. You get early access to live shows and you get exclusive deep dive series. Also, on top of that, this year's special gift edition of Restis History Club membership comes with a sensational exclusive t-shirt. It will make you the envy of all your neighbors and all the cool people in your neighbourhood, if such people exist, will admire you and want to spend
其中一些是可爱的姿态，但我怀疑它们对于典型的圣诞节早晨来说是否有点太奢侈了。所以今年，这是我对听众和观众的建议，为什么不送一些更有启发性的东西呢？为什么不送一份“历史其余部分”俱乐部会员资格作为礼物呢？对于任何喜欢汉尼拔胜过喜欢礼品篮的人来说，这是一个有眼光的选择。这是无广告收听。你每周会得到一集额外节目。你可以提前观看现场演出，并获得独家深度系列节目。此外，今年特别版的“历史其余部分”俱乐部会员资格还附赠一件轰动性的独家T恤。它会让你成为所有邻居羡慕的对象，你社区里所有酷的人，如果这样的人存在的话，都会钦佩你并想花
more time with you. So just head to the rest ishistory.com and click on gifts. That is the restishistory.com and please click on gifts. Hello there. I'm William Drimple. I am one of the hosts of Empire, the global history podcast from Gollhanger. You may remember my appearances. on The Rest is History, when we talked about Afghanistan and the East India Company. As the Ashes returned down under, Anita and I have launched a brand new empire series on the history, politics, and extraordinary cultural power of cricket. In the first episode, we dig into the origin of the ashes, England versus Australia,
更多时间和你在一起。所以只需前往therestis-history.com并点击“礼物”。那就是therestis-history.com，请点击“礼物”。你好，我是威廉·达林普。我是Gollhanger全球历史播客《帝国》的主持人之一。你可能还记得我出现在《历史其余部分》节目中，当时我们谈论了阿富汗和东印度公司。随着灰烬杯回到澳大利亚，安妮塔和我推出了一个全新的《帝国》系列，讲述板球的历史、政治和非凡的文化力量。在第一集中，我们深入探讨了灰烬杯的起源，英格兰对阵澳大利亚，
a rivalry born in the age of empires, and still shaping identity on both sides of the world. Then we travelled to India, where cricket began with an impromptu beach match, and evolved into a sport that mirrored and sometimes magnified the country's communal divides. We also talk about the great Tiger Borti who revolutionised Indian cricket in the 1960s. And for members of the Empire Club, we go still further from the great West Indian players who stood up to racism to the South African cricketers who challenged apartheid at real personal risk. If you want the full sweep of how cricket changed empires and how empires change cricket, just search for Empire wherever you get your podcasts.
这是一个诞生于帝国时代的竞争，至今仍在塑造着世界两端的身份认同。然后我们前往印度，板球在那里始于一场即兴的海滩比赛，并演变成一项反映甚至有时放大了该国社区分歧的运动。我们还谈到了在20世纪60年代彻底改变印度板球运动的伟大老虎·帕托迪。对于《帝国》俱乐部的成员，我们走得更远，从反抗种族主义的伟大西印度群岛球员到冒着真正个人风险挑战种族隔离的南非板球运动员。如果你想全面了解板球如何改变帝国以及帝国如何改变板球，只需在任何你获取播客的地方搜索《帝国》即可。
Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。